Bohr.
Oh gu play.
Gute?
E-Modes gebannt überall, das gibt es Pogu noch, Sekunde, das muss ich mal kurz nach, mal kurz checken.
Gibt es Pogu? Pogu gibt es noch, okay alles gut.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, warum sie die E-Modes von dem Kell gebannt haben.
Wahrscheinlich weil irgendjemand über irgendwas empört war im Zweifelsfall.
Ach nee, nee, ich weiß wieder.
Hat der Typ nicht irgendwas über Trump gepostet oder so?
Und das fanden alle schlimm.
Ach, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, warum Leute irgendwo gebannt werden.
Ist auch nicht alles so frisch nachvollziehbar immer.
Moin, Wolle, 604.
Danke für den Sub.
Xerolium, Cuisel, Dr. Enfiel, Puckel.
Wolle ist auch am Start.
Moment, hä?
Bei mir kam diese Meldung gar nicht.
Die kam nur auf dem Bildschirm hier.
Nicht auf dem anderen Bildschirm.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Der Twitch Chat, das ist mir jetzt schon öfters aufgefallen, aber das sehe ich auch nur, wenn ich halt...
...meinem Account eingeloggt bin und auf beiden Bildschirmen den Kram offen habe.
Das mir ist jetzt schon öfters aufgefallen, dass der Twitch Chat teilweise nicht synchron ist auf beiden Monitoren...
...und manchmal sogar Nachrichten fehlen, was eigentlich nicht sein sollte.
Oder so versetzt ankommen, dass sie vielleicht nicht fehlen, aber so versetzt ankommen, dass man sie gar nicht mehr sehen kann.
Dass es zusammen gehört.
Morgen.
Ah, ja.
Also ich bin schon ungefähr...
Lass mich mal überlegen. Eine Stunde und 15 Minuten wach oder so.
Aber ich habe nichts Großartiges gemacht. Ich habe was gefuttert.
Und einen Tee gemacht. Das war's. Ich weiß, das ist relativ wenig in knapp eineinhalb Stunden, aber was soll's?
Aber ich muss mal kurz E-Mails gucken, ob es wieder Raid-Shadow-Legends-Anfragen gibt.
Zeig mal her.
Die sind ja immer noch hartnäckig dabei.
Ihr DHL-Paket kommt bald. Ah nee, das war schon fünf Tage her. Nee, das kann es jetzt nicht sein.
Reichel sagt, sie haben eine Zahlung erhalten. Das ist auch gut.
Ich habe nämlich einen Raspberry Pi Pico W bestellt.
Weiß ich, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt. Es gibt jetzt Raspberry Pi Picos mit WLAN.
Das ist das, was ich ja von Anfang an angemeckert habe an diesen Dingern.
Dass sie ziemlich useless sind, weil sie keinen WLAN haben, aber es gibt jetzt welche mit WLAN.
Deswegen habe ich mir gleich zwei Stück bestellt, dass wir das Ganze mal ausprobieren können im Stream.
Hallo, Key für Sie verfügbar. So, so.
Ach so, immer. Das will ich überhaupt nicht spielen.
Oh nee, Opera Jakes ist wieder am Start, obwohl die doch das letzte Mal nicht wollten.
Cack Wade, Alter.
Unlogisch. So, alles klar.
Ja, guck mal, hier. Weiß ich, ob ich es mitbekommen habe, aber...
Nein, nicht die Lötstation. Auch nicht die Lötstation, sondern...
Oder auch nicht kim.com. Hier, Tenor.
Es gibt jetzt einen Raspberry Pi Pico W.
Der Raspberry Pi Pico hat ja mit dem Raspberry Pi nichts zu tun.
Das kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die denken, oh, das ist ein Raspberry Pi nur in noch kleiner.
Ist es nicht. Der Raspberry Pi ist ein ganz normaler Single Board Computer mit Linux.
Und Multitasking und allem, was man so von einer normalen ARM CPU oder normalen ARM Single Board Computer erwartet.
Der Pico ist ein eher ein Arduino ESP Konkurrent.
Also sprich, das ist ein Microcontroller, da läuft euer Sketch drauf und sonst nix.
Wenn ihr Multithreading machen wollt, was glaube ich geht, weil ich glaube, es hat zwei CPU Kerne,
müsst ihr das alles selbst machen oder irgendein Scheduler Library verwenden.
Aber es ist halt nichts mit fertigen Betriebssystemen drauf.
Geschweige denn was, wo man sich per SSH einloggen kann oder sowas.
Dafür sind die Sachen halt für Steuerung von irgendwelchen Geräten deutlich besser geeignet als der Raspberry Pi.
Als der normale Raspberry Pi.
Und er ist halt vor allem auch eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Allerdings muss ich halt sagen, ich bin immer noch skeptisch, was die Daseinsberechtigung angeht,
weil das Ding ist rein von den Specks her und ich glaube, ich habe letztens auch mal einen Benchmark gesehen.
Langsamer als in ESP32, hat weniger Flash als in ESP32, hat weniger RAM als in ESP32.
Also ich sehe die Vorteile noch nicht so ganz.
Aber das gucken wir uns an, ich habe welche bestellt für irgendwie...
Ich habe die irgendwie bereichend, glaube ich, bestellt.
Ja, irgendwie für fünf Euro oder zwei Stück, kostet aber sechs Euro Lieferung, was ziemlich sakt ist.
Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht...
Ne, die Dinger sind schon ziemlich klein.
Die Dinger sind schon ziemlich klein.
ESP, also die sind kleiner als in ESP32.
Ich meine, ESP32 selbst ist ja auch nur so, aber die Picos sind ein Ticken kleiner als die...
Zumindest das letzte Mal, wo ich mir die Bildchen mal im Vergleich angeguckt habe.
Die Picos sind ein Ticken kleiner als die meisten ESP32 Boards.
Vielleicht ein bisschen vergleichbar mit den Pico ESP32, aber die sind halt auch eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Ne, nicht Pico, äh...
Hier. Also die sind ungefähr vergleichbar mit den Dingern.
Dass es beides Pico heißt, ist halt einfach weil es klein ist, hat nichts miteinander zu tun.
Die sind halt teurer.
Also ich bin mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Mal gespannt, wie es mit Library-Verfügbarkeit aussieht.
Wie es mit Arduino-Support aussieht.
Das ist ja für mich fast das Beste.
Ich glaube, das ist das Beste.
Wie es mit Arduino-Support aussieht. Das ist ja für mich fast das Beste am ESP32.
Dass du die Kombination machen kannst aus denen in ihrem Entwicklungsframework
für unter der Haube Dinger, die man vielleicht braucht, plus Arduino.
Das ist eh, finde ich so mein Lieblingssetup.
Deswegen bin ich froh, dass Platform.io das jetzt offiziell auch mit den neuen Versionen wieder unterstützt.
Gibt es den Prozessor auch einzeln?
Ja, ja, gibt es.
Haben wir schon gefunden.
Du kriegst so eine Rolle. Du kannst so eine Filmrolle kaufen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sich das korrekterweise nennt.
Aber ihr wisst was, ich meine diese Rollen, wo die ganzen Dinger, die ganzen Komponenten drauf sind.
Da gibt es auch den Raspberry Pi Pico-Chip auf der Rolle ohne Board.
Gibt es auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich eine Rolle suchen kann.
Strip. Ich weiß nicht, was ich suchen muss.
SMD?
Ja, so sieht das dann aus.
Aber das habe ich RP, das habe ich nämlich letztens schon gesehen.
Das kannst du hier nicht kaufen, aber gibt es.
Ja, guck hier.
Und die gibt es auch auf dieser Rolle.
Zum Rolle mit 5000 Stück oder so.
Wenn man es denn braucht.
Wenn man irgendwas pfeifhändiges entworfen hat und will das jetzt am Fließband produzieren, dann aufgeht es.
Wobei Fließband ist es ja nicht.
Ja, bin ich mal gespannt, wie das da mit dem Arduino Support beziehungsweise den eigenen Libraries aussieht und warum ich den verwenden sollte versus ein ESP32.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das was taugt.
Ich meine, das mit Abstand sinnvollste, das mit Abstand sinnvollste Projekt war ja eh das hier.
Guckt mal Leute, also was wir hier mal programmiert haben.
Also wenn das nicht absolut jeden davon überzeugen sollte, sich einen ESP32 mit Display zu kaufen, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Guck mal, wie schnell das Display updatet hier.
Eindeutig einen ESP32, wenn ich die Auswahl habe immer einen ESP32, immer.
Also für Sachen zum Selbstmachen.
Wenn es irgendwas fertiges ist, wo ich beispielsweise WLED oder TAS Motor oder sonst was draufflaschen kann, dann ist es mir egal.
Dann eventuell sogar ein D1 Mini oder irgendwas, was halt möglichst billig ist.
Und was die D1 Minis, also die originalen D1 Minis haben den Vorteil, die verkraften auch was anderes als 3,3 oder 5 Volt Input.
Die machen glaube ich offiziell bis 12 Volt Input, also mit Spannungswandler am Eingang, aber die werden wohl äußerst heiß damit.
Ja, die Raspberry Pi Picos sollten, müssten noch kleiner als die D1 Minis sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Länge, aber in der Breite auf jeden Fall und insgesamt auf jeden Fall weniger Fläche.
Was der mit dem Display gekostet hat, der da, 15 Euro oder so.
AliExpress, ETGO Display.
Mal gucken, ob das irgendwie ein Vergleichbild gibt.
D1 Mini versus...
Hier.
Oh nee, ich hab nix gesagt. Guck mal da. Die sind ja noch größer.
Ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, das fällt ja auf Bild nicht auf, ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, dass, ja dann ist es ja noch unsinniger.
Warum genau ist es so, dass die D1 Minis noch größer sind als die D1 Minis?
Weil die D1 Minis sind ja noch größer als die D1 Minis.
Das fällt ja auf Bild nicht auf, ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, dass, ja dann ist es ja noch unsinniger.
Warum genau sollte ich da einen Raspberry Pi Pico verwenden?
Ich meine die ESP32 Boards, die gibt es ja auch, die D1 Mini Variante, die sind ein Ticken breiter, weil die hier noch eine zweite Pin-Reihe haben, aber es gibt auch ESP32.
Dann verstehe ich den Sinn gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich einfach, weil es Raspberry Pi im Namen hat und das alle abfeiern.
Das war das Board, was wir hier verwendet haben.
Das Board ist tatsächlich ganz nice, weil du hast nicht nur ein Display, du hast alle möglichen Pin aus, du hast aber auch einen Button.
Du hast einen Reset-Button und einen, nee du hast zwei normale Buttons glaube ich sogar, die kannst du als normale Buttons verwenden.
Das war ganz praktisch und es gibt jede Menge Gehäuse zum 3D-Drucken dafür.
AliExpress ist aktuell ziemlich teuer.
Doch die neuen haben ja Bluetooth und WLAN jetzt.
Das musste auch erstmal schaffen. Was ein bescheuertes Werbefoto oder?
Mit dem Display, wo Fail drauf steht. Naja, gut China, China ist ein Kram.
Was ist aber auch komisch, dass der Kram auf Amazon günstiger ist als über AliExpress.
Nee, der hat auch Bluetooth?
Hab ich gelesen?
Ach Moment.
Ach der hat theoretisch Bluetooth, aber die haben es irgendwie nicht ange- oder was?
Oh Mann, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Das hab ich nämlich auch gelesen, das Modell ist mit einem WiFi und Bluetooth-Chip ausgestattet.
Läuft Pyhol auf dem ESP32?
Pyhol ist irgendeine Python, sonst was Web-Anwendung mit unter der Haube DNS-Mask, was unter Linux läuft.
Das kannst du auf dem komplett knicken. Da läuft ja kein Linux drauf.
Wie gesagt, das ist kein Raspberry Pi. Der heißt nur so.
Warum haben die den Bluetooth-Kram nicht angeschlossen vor dem Chip?
Wahrscheinlich bringen die demnächst einen Raspberry Pi WB raus mit Bluetooth und WiFi.
Das ist ja ziemlich beknackt, aber ok.
Direkt zur Rolle, genau das hab ich gesagt.
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Das meine ich nicht. Ich meinte die Rolle, wo nur der Chip drauf ist.
Aber das ist natürlich auch leicht übertrieben.
Ich meine, wenn man es braucht, warum nicht?
Aber da musste schon irgendwelche super 5-headigen Produkte am Stück herstellen, dass sich das lohnt.
Na ja.
Leute, soll ich euch was erzählen?
Es ist soweit bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Dramatische Pause, MonkaS.
Dramatische Pause, es ist soweit.
Wir gucken uns heute Abend mal... Nein, noch nicht, aber bald.
Wir gucken uns heute Abend mal wieder ein bisschen...
Und diesmal nicht rein Just For Fun Stellenanzeigen an.
Ich hab schon zwei Sachen unabhängig, die werde ich mir auch nicht im Stream angucken.
Also vielleicht doch, ich überleg gerade.
Nee, eher nicht.
Nee, das guck ich mir nicht im Stream an.
Also ich hab schon zwei Sachen, wo ich mich bei einer auf jeden Fall bewerben werde, weil das passt echt gut.
Das hab ich daher, das kann ich jetzt an der Stelle mal erzählen, das ist ja relativ abstrakt.
Also muss ich keine Namen nennen und sonst was.
Bei dem einen werde ich mich bewerben, weil ich jemanden kenne, der dort arbeitet.
Und der war mal bei uns, da wo ich jetzt arbeite im Team.
Und mit dem hab ich noch ab und zu Kontakt und die haben gesagt, die suchen immer händeringend Leute und ja, passt eh ganz gut.
Hab ich aber noch nicht.
Und mit dem anderen hab ich nächste Woche einen Termin.
Also da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht, sage ich jetzt nicht, was es ist.
Wobei ich kann, doch eine Sache kann ich sagen, das eine ist ein Finanzdienstleister in Frankfurt.
Das wäre im Prinzip irgendwie nicht fast um die Ecke, nicht wirklich um die Ecke, fast um die Ecke.
Allerdings zum größten Teil Homeoffice und nicht so wie bei uns, sondern wirklich auch garantiert.
Und das andere, da wo ich eher drauf sage ich mal schiele, ist was ganz anderes.
Noch nicht mal in Frankfurt.
Vielleicht ja.
Also das eine ist in Frankfurt ein Finanzdienstleister und das andere ist ganz woanders.
Da kann ich euch aber nicht sagen wo.
Weil wenn ich euch sage wo und ihr sucht nach was weiß ich, IT Rechenzentrum sonst was oder Rechenzentrum,
das müsst ihr nicht suchen, irgendwie auch entfernt nach IT und diesem kleinen Minikaff,
dann wisst ihr sofort was es ist.
Da gibt es nicht so viel sonst.
Aber das ist hundertprozentig Homeoffice.
Wobei das stimmt nicht, es ist nicht hundertprozentig Homeoffice, doch es ist hundertprozentig Homeoffice.
Aber es gibt irgendwie zwei oder drei Veranstaltungen im Jahr, wo man sich wünscht,
dass die Leute der Sache dann beiwohnen vor Ort.
Soll mir recht sein.
Komme ich in zwei Stunden auch hin, das passt schon.
Also zweimal im Jahr irgendwo hinfahren.
Wichtig ist für mich, dass das vertraglich geregelt ist was Homeoffice angeht.
Nicht so diese Geschichte mit ja im Absprache mit dem Chef oder ja wenn es uns danach ist,
dann könnte man das machen und ja jetzt könnte man das.
Wichtig für mich ist, dass das vertraglich geregelt ist.
Und nachdem das auch schon bei denen in der Stellenanzeige steht, dann ist das denke ich mal kein Problem.
Ja ich muss eine Kündigungsfrist einhalten.
Ich habe ziemlich blöde Kündigungsfristen.
Das heißt ich muss drei Monate warten, aber es kann auch sein, dass man das einvernehmlich macht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aktuell ist es auf jeden Fall nicht spruchreif.
Ich gucke einfach, was es so gibt.
Obwohl das eine finde ich wirklich nice, das beim anderen Frankfurter Finanzdienstleister.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es da so viel geiler ist als bei uns.
Zumindest, zumindest und das ist halt das, was bei uns auch den Ausschlag gegeben hat jetzt.
Zumindest ist es bei denen 100% Homeoffice.
Ja und der ausschlaggebende Punkt bei mir war letztendlich zwei Sachen.
Bei mir wurde ja auf der Arbeit umstrukturiert, also mein aktuelles Team wurde ja aufgelöst
und wir sind jetzt noch vier von den verbleibenden plus voran.
Das wird eh komplettes Chaos werden das nächste halbe Jahr.
Ja, ja, das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen, weil es ja so ist, dass bei solchen Umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen
das Knowhow und die Aufgaben nicht irgendwie sich ändern.
Also von heute auf morgen, also sprich die Leute, die von was Ahnung haben,
aber jetzt offiziell dann vielleicht nicht mehr in dem Team sind, das dafür zuständig ist,
haben ja trotzdem noch davon Ahnung und die neuen nicht.
Also sprich, die Umstrukturierung ist komplett übers Knie gebrochen und schlecht geplant.
Das wird extremes Chaos geben, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Und das andere ist, das andere ist, das wobei das würde ich theoretisch mitmachen,
hätte ich keine Schmerzen mit, ich habe hier schon öfters da wirre Sachen mitgemacht.
Das andere ist, dass sie sich jetzt überlegt haben, es gibt kein vertraglich geregeltes
und also vom Anteil her mögliches Homeoffice, also sprich,
die wollen nicht in den Vertrag reinschreiben Homeoffice, auf gar keinen Fall.
Die wollen das immer auf so einer komischen, wenn es uns danach ist Basis haben.
Das geht mir schon extrem gegen den Strich.
Also so nach dem Motto, ja heute ist es okay, morgen nicht okay,
dann noch weniger, dann wieder ein bisschen mehr.
Also ich glaube es geht los, man muss sich doch irgendwie mal ein bisschen drauf verlassen können,
was Sache ist, man kann doch nicht alles immer im Monatsrhythmus ändern.
Ein Kollege von mir ist sogar umgezogen.
Also es wurde damals nämlich bei uns angekündigt, ja wir haben jetzt neue vertragliche Regelwerke
für Homeoffice und generell von nicht aus der Firma aus arbeiten.
Und er hat gesagt, ja das mache ich.
Und dann haben die ihm die ganze Zeit auch immer wieder gesagt, ja das passt, das passt, das passt, das passt.
Der ist in der Zwischenzeit umgezogen und jetzt sagen sie, ne passt nicht.
Und jetzt sagt er auch, ja dann passt es für mich auch nicht mehr.
So und bei mir ist es glücklicherweise nicht so schlimm.
Also bin ich nicht umgezogen oder so.
Aber den hat es wirklich ganz hart getroffen.
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein, diese komplette Unsicherheit, heute könnte man, morgen kann man nicht.
So und bei uns haben sie sich jetzt halt überlegt, die Leute sollen mal wieder 50% ins Büro kommen.
Das mache ich nicht.
Das werde ich auf Dauer nicht machen.
Ich gucke mir das nächste Woche mal an.
Also ich gehe nächste Woche Montag mal hingucken.
Ja und das Schöne ist, wenn man mal so rumguckt, es gibt ja durchaus nicht wenige Remote Stellen.
Jaja das wird richtig MonkaS.
Also ich werde das nächste Woche machen, um mich nochmal zu versichern, wie beschissen das eigentlich ist Bahn zu fahren.
Aber neben den zwei Sachen, die ich da jetzt schon in Aussicht ist zu viel.
Das eine will ich ja nicht mal wirklich machen.
Das ist einfach mal so ein bisschen gucken.
Ja neben diesen zwei Sachen, ich brauche kein 9 Euro Ticket.
Ich habe Monatskarte.
Wenn ich Montag sage, meine ich Dienstag.
Ja das werde ich nicht machen.
Ich werde schon nach Möglichkeit mein Zeug ordentlich übergeben.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ja auch überhaupt noch nicht spruchreif.
Aber ich nehme das jetzt zum Anlass wirklich zu gucken.
Und neben den zwei Sachen, die ich da schon ins Auge gefasst habe, werden wir heute Abend nochmal zusammen Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Ist das so?
Habe ich mich nie mit beschäftigt.
Kann sein ja.
Wenn wir uns heute Abend nochmal Stellenanzeigen angucken, aber jetzt halt wirklich was.
Nicht nur just for fun, sondern wirklich was, wo es halt was gibt, was mich interessiert.
Und Leute, unabhängig von.
Was ist hier los?
Und unabhängig von meinem feinfertigen LinkedIn Profil, ich habe mir ein eigenes LinkedIn Profil gemacht.
Ich habe noch nichts eingetragen, aber ich habe ein persönliches LinkedIn Profil gemacht.
Ich muss mir noch überlegen, wie ich das am besten mache, weil ich möchte nicht.
Mein LinkedIn Profil irgendwie mit YouTube oder so in Verbindung bringen.
Also das wird definitiv nicht das benutzte LinkedIn Profil sein dafür.
Ich meine, vielleicht liege ich das LinkedIn Profil auch.
Ich meine, ich mache ein Foto rein, das ist jetzt nicht super aussagekräftig.
Also man erkennt mich da zwar drauf, aber ich denke nicht, dass mich aufgrund dieses Fotos irgendjemand da großartig in der Bahn ansprechen würde oder so.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht liege ich das LinkedIn Profil auch.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall noch eine ordentliche Skillliste mal zusammenstellen von Dingen, die ich auskenne bzw. Dinge, die ich machen will.
Also ich werde bevorzugt Dinge, die ich machen will und mich auskenne hinschreiben und nicht C++ Microcontroller.
Und dann kommt noch jemand an und fragt, willst du nicht C++ für uns machen?
Stellt euch mal vor, ich werde professioneller C++ Entwickler.
Ne, habe ich zu wenig Ahnung von und würde ich auch im Leben nicht machen wollen.
Also, dass ich ein bisschen Ahnung davon habe, wäre tatsächlich gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich meine, es muss ja nicht zwangsläufig das exakt Gebiet sein, wo ich dann was mache, aber dass man davon Ahnung hat,
es ist ja gerade was WebAssembly angeht, ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Ich meine, das ist aktuell voll angesagt.
Ja, gucken wir mal. Heute Abend. Wann heute Abend war oder heute Nachmittag? Keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal schauen.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so einfach. Das muss einem ja auch erstmal alles einfallen.
Deswegen, da muss ich mal in mich, das ist ja das, was ich gemeint habe, da muss ich mal in mich gehen und mir eine Skilllist überlegen,
was ich schon alles gemacht habe.
Ich meine, wir können so Dinge reinschreiben, Infrastructure as Code ist cool, weil da kann ich reinschreiben Puppet und Ansible.
Ich kann reinschreiben 15 Jahre Linux Erfahrung.
Soll ich euch mal sagen, wie das mit dem Arbeitszeugnis gelaufen ist?
Also wir haben jetzt ja vorgesetzten Wechsel, da kann man ja eine Zeugnis anfordern.
Und ich habe meinen alten Chef gefragt, wie sieht es denn aus mit Zeugnis?
Und da haben die ihm gesagt, er darf noch keine Zeugnisse schreiben aktuell.
Und ich habe schon jemand vom Betriebsrat angeschrieben gehabt und habe gesagt, was ist denn hier los?
Aber ein paar Tage später hatte ich ein Gespräch mit meinem neuen Chef und habe das auch nochmal angesprochen mit dem Zeugnis,
wie das sein kann, dass der alt nicht schreiben soll.
Und hat gesagt, der kümmert sich jetzt drum und ja du darfst jederzeit anfragen, aber machen müssen sie es nicht.
So und er hat sich da jetzt drum gekümmert und dann kam auch mein alter Chef nochmal und hat gesagt, hier er sammelt jetzt ein.
Und ich konnte jetzt quasi mehr oder weniger mein Zeugnis selber schreiben.
Zwar nicht exakt die Formulierung, aber die Themen.
Und Leute, ich habe da Buzzword Bingo of Doom drinnen.
Warte mal, ich habe irgendwo ein Bild glaube ich.
Warte mal.
Wenn ich kein Bild habe, muss ich es raussuchen.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Wo habe ich das Bild? Ich habe irgendwo das Bild.
Ich habe da wirklich Bullshit Bingo of Doom gemacht.
Moment, wo habe ich das Bild? Alter, warum habe ich so viele Bilder?
Hier, also was habe ich?
Also was heißt Bullshit?
Ich konnte da nicht so viel hinschreiben, weil das irgendwie der Platz ja auch beschränkt ist.
Also ich habe mich da schon auf die wichtigsten Buzzwords beschränkt.
Also was habe ich drin? Ich habe drin schon DevOps und dann habe ich dahinter stehen die Themen.
Git, GitHub, Bitbucket, GitLab, Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery,
Release Management für circa 3000 Linux-Systeme, Infrastructure as Code, Automatisierung,
Kontenerisierung, Automatisierung, Puppet, Ansible, Bash, Ruby, Groovy, Python-Scripting, Let's Encrypt,
Linux-System Engineering, Red Hat, Ubuntu, Hochverfügbarkeit, Ausfall, Sicherheit, Security, Kontonerisierung, Skalierung,
Tool-Entwicklung, C-Sharp.net, Go, JavaScript.
Ich lese euch jetzt den Rest nicht vor, das ist teilweise ein bisschen firmenspezifisch.
Was kann ich denn sonst noch jetzt vorlesen?
Das kann ich nicht vorlesen, das ist zu.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf, man kann nicht jedes einzelne Buzzword reinschreiben.
Okay, also was gucken wir uns heute für Videos an?
Ja, ist klar, wer kennt diese Situation nicht?
Man ist Pilot und hat einen Freund, der auch Pilot ist, der weiß aber nicht, dass man auch Pilot ist,
weil man ja so gut mit dem befreundet ist und man so Sachen zwischen Piloten sich nicht erzählt,
dass man auch zufälligerweise Pilot ist und sich wahrscheinlich beim Fliegen als Pilot kennen...
Ja, legit, legit, alles klar, glaube ich sofort.
Kubernetes-Stream, ich habe bei mir daheim ausgemistet.
Ich habe hier zwei Raspberry Pi 4 rumliegen und ich habe unten im Wohnzimmer noch einen,
den ich ausmisten werde, aber das ist glaube ich ein Dreier
und dann könnten wir einen Raspberry Pi Kubernetes-Cluster machen.
Einfach weil es geht, nicht weil es sinnvoll ist.
Es ist eigentlich komplett unsinnig, aber okay.
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Also ich meine, rein für den Meme-Faktor, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es für Ubuntu 16.04...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Containerkram auf dem Staubsauger läuft.
Ja, das ist eine arme CPU, das ist ja schon mal was.
Docker-Container auf dem Staubsauger, das wäre es, Alter.
Der hat sich resettet vor einer Weile wieder.
Muss ich erstmal wieder flashen.
Die Go-Binaries an sich ist nicht das Problem, es ist die Frage, ob der Colonel darauf alle Features hat.
Weil zumindest bei Docker-Container brauchst du natürlich die Standardgeschichte von Namespaces, Cgroups und sonst was.
Du brauchst aber auch Overlay FS und hast du nicht gesehen, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Da müsste man mal schauen, ob ich meinen Staubsauger in Kubernetes-Cluster packen kann.
Das müsste man tatsächlich mal gucken.
Was ist das?
Naja, also was gucken wir uns an?
Ich würde sagen, was ist der schnellste Putzroboter der Welt?
Okay, wir lassen uns erst einmal, das ist Standard, das müssen wir jede Woche machen.
Wir lassen uns eine Runde von LevelCapture baiten.
Er wird wieder irgendwelche unnützten Sachen erzählen, das DICE jetzt gelernt hat.
Aus den Fehlern in Battlefield 2042 und am Ende fragt er uns dann, was wir davon denken.
Und ob wir jetzt glauben, dass Battlefield 2042 in einem better Spot ist.
Ich wette mit euch, sowas kommt da wieder, weil das macht er jede Woche.
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen schreiben es die Leute auch jede Woche, keine Ahnung.
So, wir müssen ein bisschen lauter machen, weil ansonsten verstehen wir nichts.
Singleplayer Battlefield Game? Seriously?
Das, wo absolut nicht die Stärken in den letzten Jahren drin lagen.
Ja, mittlerweile, also, ich muss da einfach mal was zu sagen.
Also, es ist so, dass qualitativ heute bei den Games wirklich sehr viel zu wünschen übrig lässt.
Spiele kommen raus, sind nicht nur unfertig, haben den Content removed,
den Teile davor drinne hatten, sind verbackt as fuck, kommen quasi als Early Access.
Also, das ist alles nicht schön.
Also, viele und gerade bei vielen AAA-Games ist das heute in einem Zustand.
Das hättest du dir früher nicht erlauben können, die so zu releasen.
Aber, da will ich mich jetzt gar nicht drüber auslassen.
Eine Sache, die mir ähnlich stark auf den Sack geht, ist diese extreme Empörung
überall über jeden Scheiß in dieser Richtung.
Also, mir geht es nicht darum, dass man jetzt sich da drüber aufregt,
dass Blizzard einen gebated hat mit WarCraft Deforged oder sowas.
Da kann man sich den ganzen Tag drüber aufregen, ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und das ist auch jeder, der dafür Geld bezahlt hat,
hat natürlich auch irgendwo das Recht, sich drüber aufzuregen.
Und selbst wenn der nicht Geld bezahlt hat,
man kann sich über Diablo Immortal den ganzen Tag über aufregen, ohne.
Aber diese getriggerte Empörung überall wegen jedem Scheiß
regt mich einfach auch im Gaming-Segment auf.
Ja, da kommt irgendwie ein Statement raus, wo eigentlich nichts drinsteht,
wo du dann sagen könntest, ja, okay, üblicher PR-Bullshit.
Aber irgendjemand entdeckt dann in diesem Presse-Statement das,
was weiß ich, das Wort, was da drin verwendet wurde,
haben auch Leute, die er nicht mag, schon mal verwendet.
Und da gibt es einen riesen Shitstorm, weil irgendjemand dort
das falsche Wort in der Pressemeldung oder so verwendet hat.
Da wird sich so krass über jeden Scheiß mittlerweile aufgeregt.
Und die Leute sind wegen den kleinsten Kleinigkeiten heute super empört.
Und ich meine, lasst den Leuten doch mal ein bisschen die Ruhe.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass bei jeder Äußerung,
die ein Entwickler oder ein Community-Manager oder sonst wer irgendwo
im offiziellen Forum oder auf Twitter oder sonst wie postet,
dass der Angst haben muss, dass morgen aufgebrachte 150.000 Leute
quasi virtuell brandschatzend über seinen Twitter-Account herziehen.
Also ich meine, dann muss man sich doch nicht wundern,
wenn die Responses die letzten Jahre über so inhaltsleer geworden sind.
Man kann sich doch, ich meine, ich beschwer mich da auch darüber,
dass wenn du heute irgendwelche Meldungen bekommst,
die sind so wischiwaschi, dass du eigentlich gar nichts mit anfangen kannst.
Du hast kaum noch Entwickler, die wirklich mal Statements schreiben.
Du hast kaum noch Community-Manager, die sinnvolle Sachen schreiben.
Das ist alles nur so wischiwaschi Zeug.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich kann es ihnen gar nicht mal übel nehmen.
Wenn die wirklich was Konkretes schreiben, ist wieder Gott um die Welt getriggert.
Überlegt euch mal, was los wäre, damals 2008 oder so,
da hat sich, ich glaube sogar Jeff Kaplan war es damals,
als er noch bei World of Warcraft war, hat sich für World of Warcraft
Instance Design oder so, oh, mein Stream hängt, kann das sein?
Mein Vorschau, mein Vorschau hängt.
Ja, da hat sich Jeff Kaplan auf der Bühne bei der BlizzCon hingestellt
und hat gesagt, wenn ihr schlechte Heiler in der Gruppe habt,
dann kickt sie einfach.
Das ist kein Quote, sinngemäß hat er so was gesagt.
Das ist jetzt kein Zitat gewesen, aber sinngemäß hat er gesagt,
wenn ihr schlechte Heiler oder schlechte Supporter,
schlechte Team-Mats in der Gruppe habt, dann kickt sie.
Was meint ihr denn, was heute los wäre,
wenn der das auf der Bühne gesagt hätte?
Dann hätte sich mal ganz Twitter darüber ausgekotzt,
wie uninclusive und sonst was Jeff Kaplan ist
und der muss rausgeworfen werden,
weil der verdrückt natürlich nicht die Ideale der Gaming-Kommi
und bla, bla, bla, bla.
Deswegen sagt heute keiner irgendwelche klaren Sachen,
sondern macht alles nur so wischiwaschi.
Es gibt Sachen, über die kann man sich wirklich aufregen.
Guckt euch Diablo Immortal an,
da könnte ich mir die ganze Tag darüber aufregen.
Aber diese krasse Empörung über jeden Scheiß,
da geht mir in vielen Bereichen auf den Sack.
Der wäre heute richtig die Kacke am Dampfen.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer noch,
und wo man auch daran sieht, dass egal, was man macht,
es niemals richtig machen kann,
ist, ich weiß, das Beispiel habe ich schon öfter gebracht,
Recycle-Story, aber mein Lieblingsbeispiel
ist Tracer aus Overwatch.
Da kam ja der Comic raus damals.
Das könnte sogar noch zu Beta-Zeiten gewesen sein.
Da gab es einen Comic mit Tracer in London,
wo man Tracer gesehen hat mit ihrer Freundin beim Kaffee trinken.
Das war vollkommen egal.
Man hat gesehen, Tracer hat eine Freundin.
Tracer wäre lesbisch, hat man gesehen in diesem Comic.
Da dachte ich mir damals,
das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich cooler Move von Blizzard,
von ihrer Aushängeschild-Charakter,
offiziell in einem Comic das mal klar zu sagen.
Das finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht von Blizzard.
Daraufhin kam von den Leuten,
die immer geflamed haben,
dass das alles im Gaming-Bereich zu unterrepräsentiert ist,
die gleichen Leute haben sich auf Twitter aufgeregt,
was das für eine Sauerei wäre,
dass Tracer lesbisch ist.
Das habe ich erst mal nicht verstanden.
Wie kann man sich denn darüber aufregen?
Ihr seid doch die gleichen Leute,
die sich darüber aufregen,
dass es sonst nicht richtig repräsentiert ist.
Die Begründung war,
das geht nicht an, dass es Tracer ist,
weil Tracer ist ein Charakter,
das ist ein Charakter,
der explizit für das männliche Auge designed wurde.
Wie kann das sein, dass der lesbisch ist?
Das war der Punkt,
weil Leute, ihr seid einfach alle nicht mehr zurechnungsfähig.
Ihr seid nicht mehr ganz dicht im Kopf.
Ihr könnt sich doch nicht vorher beschweren,
dass es zu unterrepräsentiert ist.
Dann geht ein Spielehersteller hin
und macht sein Aushängeschild.
Sagt das mal ganz klar.
Oder bekennt sich dazu, sagt das klar.
Und dann beschwert man sich auch wieder darüber.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Also das hier ist Tracer,
wer das nicht kennt aus Overwatch.
Das ist Tracer.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Die hätten anstatt Tracer Zarya genommen.
So.
Was meint ihr, was dann los gewesen wäre?
Dann hätten die sich drüber aufgeregt.
Ja, stereotypische Darstellung in Blizzard spielen.
Meine Güte, es ist egal, was du machst.
Doch, das sind die gleichen Personen, Shryker.
In dem Fall waren das die gleichen Personen.
Ich hab mir Twitter-Profile angeguckt.
Die haben sich früher darüber aufgeregt,
dass es nicht richtig repräsentiert ist.
Und jetzt, wo es das wird, war es auch nicht richtig.
Natürlich gibt es auch immer noch andere,
die sich dazu aufregen.
Aber was für eine Idiotie.
Das ist so hängen geblieben.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, es ist vorbei.
Ich kann das teilweise nicht mehr ernst nehmen.
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Wo ist das Problem?
Deswegen kann ich es auch verstehen,
dass viele Entwickler heute nicht mehr im Forum aktiv sind.
Dass viele Entwickler teilweise ihr Game gar nicht mehr
selbst spielen wollen.
Ich sage nicht, dass das die Schuld von den Fans ist.
Auch zum größten Teil die Corporate-Welt,
dass sie da keinen Bock mehr drauf haben,
weil Spiele heute anders entwickelt werden wie früher.
Weil Spiele heute nicht mehr von Leuten entwickelt werden,
die das beste Spiel machen wollen,
was sie selbst gerne spielen wollen,
sondern dass es irgendwelche Stonks-Entscheidungen gibt.
Aber es trägt sicherlich auch diese ganze Massenempörung
über jeden Scheiß dazu bei,
dass sich ein Entwickler oder Mitarbeiter
selbst postantwortet oder nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich hätte keine Schmerzen mit,
wenn die sich auch mal ordentlich äußern würden.
Wenn da z.B. irgendjemand wieder einen Vorschlag macht,
irgendeinen Overwatch-Brancesspieler,
der der Meinung ist, er weiß, wie man das Game umdesignen muss,
sodass es richtig geil wird für alle,
postet dann wieder einen total sinnleeren Vorschlag.
Da würde ich als Entwickler gerne drunterschreiben können.
Nein, das ist Schwachsinn, das funktioniert nicht, weil so und so.
Aber nicht dieses super in Watte gepackte immer,
wo du permanent davon ausgehen musst,
irgendjemand ist jetzt gleich getriggert
und shitstormt wild rum auf Twitter.
Ich hatte wirklich kein Problem,
die sollen ruhig sagen, was Sache ist.
Müssen dann auch verkraften, dass man das nicht so sieht.
Aber ich hab da keine Schmerzen mit.
Mir ist das lieber als 5 Seiten um den heißen Brei rumgerede.
Es gibt heute kaum noch Statements von irgendwelchen Herstellern,
Pressesprechern und Entwicklern,
wo du irgendwas Sinnvolles daraus rauslesen kannst.
Das ist alles so, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Da steht dann so Sachen drin wie, ja, wir haben highest standards.
We are always designing player first.
Da steht immer so der gleiche generic shit drinne.
Guckt euch doch mal die aktuellen Gaming-Präsentationen.
Was war letztens das Bethesda-Game-Festzeug
und das Xbox-Kram und die E30?
Guckt euch die Streams an, das ist so nichtsagend
und so identitätslos alles, so langweilig.
Die sind alle nur noch permanent super thrilled,
amazed, excited.
Und dann erzählen so Dinger, die schlicht ergreifend nicht stimmen.
Da hat sich doch letztens irgendjemand hingestellt,
als Modern Warfare 2 angekündigt wurde und hat gesagt,
ähm, wie war das?
In 2019, when Modern Warfare was released,
it changed everything.
Da dachte ich mir so, okay, was genau hat das gechanged?
Das sind einfach so inhaltslose Dinger,
die da hingeschmissen werden, ohne Bezug zur Realität
und einfach komplett so wischiwasch, du kannst damit nichts anfangen.
Was genau hat bitte schön Modern Warfare 2019 groß gechanged?
Es sah mal ordentlich zeitgemäß aus, okay, aber changed everything.
Das hört sich so an, als war das das bahnbrechendste Game,
was die letzten 20 Jahre rausgekommen ist.
Das ist es halt nicht.
Ja.
Was ich halt auch teilweise echt cringy finde, ist,
wenn die irgendwelche Entwickler hinsetzen,
die dann ihr Spiel loben müssen und du merkst richtig,
die wollen da gar nicht sitzen.
Irgendwelche BWL-Leute haben sich überlegt,
wir müssen das jetzt präsentieren.
Und die Leute sitzen da und denken sich so,
was sage ich denn da jetzt? Keine Ahnung.
Und das, obwohl die garantiert im Vorfeld schon ihren Text parat hatten,
was sie eigentlich sagen sollen.
Und wenn man nichts zu zeigen hat, aber trotzdem eine halbe Stunde was zeigen muss,
dann kommt halt so nichts sagender Marketing-Blubberkram raus,
wie die letzten Gaming-Streams,
wie die Windows-11-Präsentationen oder sonstige Geschichten.
Einfach nur inhaltsleeres, so hypen, aber ohne Hype ist das.
Wie könnte man das beschreiben?
Diese ganzen Veranstaltungen versuchen die Leute zu hypen,
aber ohne die Basis zu haben,
dass es einen Hype überhaupt realistisch geben kann.
Guck, es ist ungefähr so.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich sagen würde,
okay, ich muss mir irgendwas überlegen.
Also irgendwas, was euch komplett am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, Leute, ich kaufe mir jetzt einen neuen Fernseher.
Das geht euch komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Aber ich würde permanent zwei Wochen lang in meinen Videos und Streams erzählen,
Leute, ich bin so krass excited, ich habe einen neuen Fernseher.
Alter, bester Fernseher aller Zeiten.
Es ist die krasseste Fernseh-Experience ever.
Wisst ihr, ich würde mich einfach zwei Wochen voll irgendwas reinhypen
in was, was euch eigentlich nicht interessiert.
Beziehungsweise irgendwas, wo es überhaupt keinen Grund gibt für euch,
dass es euch interessieren sollte.
Wenn man Gameplay-Streams macht, mir wäre es viel lieber,
die zeigen einfach eine halbe Stunde wirklich was von ihrem Game.
Aber wie ist denn mittlerweile Gaming-Streams bzw. Ankündigungen?
Das ist doch eher so.
Wobei, früher hat es Nintendo, finde ich, ganz gut gemacht.
Mittlerweile sind die Nintendo-Dinger auch komplett unsinnig.
Aber warum zeigen die nicht einfach eine halbe Stunde lang fünf Games
und zeigen halt das, was man davon zeigen kann?
Was interessant ist, wo du siehst, wie sich das Game spielt,
vielleicht irgendwie einen Story-Teaser, was auch immer.
Aber nein, heute ist das so, erst mal kommt eine Anmoderation,
wo der Typ erzählt, früher, als er klein war,
hat er das mit seinen Eltern auch schon gespielt.
Und er ist so emotional engaged in dieser Spielereihe.
Und er freut sich schon seit Jahren, dass endlich mal wieder jetzt was rauskommt.
Und jetzt ist es so weit, jetzt ist er super thrilled und super hyped
und super excited, das endlich ankündigen zu können.
Und jetzt kündigt er das an.
Aber er kündigt das nicht selber an, weil er hat jetzt
einen super krassen Mega-Influencer von YouTube hier,
der das Ganze mit ihm ankündigt.
Und hat den Chef-Entwickler auch noch hier das Ganze mit ankündigt.
Aber bevor wir das Game ankündigen,
interview ich die anderen zwei jetzt erst noch mal,
wie es an dem Game, was wir nicht zeigen dürfen, ist,
zu arbeiten an einem Game, was wir nicht zeigen dürfen.
Dann interviewt er den Entwicklern und sagt,
boah, das ist mein most exciting Job.
Ich bin so grateful, dass ich dort arbeiten kann.
Und das ist das geilste Spiel aller Zeiten.
Dann wird der Influencer noch interviewt und erzählt,
ich bin euch so dankbar, dass ich hier sein kann
und das ist für mich alles so mitreißend und toll.
Und dann sagt er, und jetzt haben wir 15 Minuten
um den heißen Pral rum geredet, jetzt kommt der Trailer.
Da kommt ein Trailer.
Thüdyt. Thüdyt.
Dschrrrrk.
So, fünf Sekunden.
Und dann sagt er, boah, was war das?
Unglaublich.
Sowas habe ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Ich bin ich platz gleich so wahnsinnig bin ich halt mega halt ihr seid bestimmt genauso halb wie ich
Und dann haben die das tatsächlich geschafft 30 minuten über ein game zu reden von dem nun ich siehst
Nichts weiß
Keine Ahnung hast du was irgendwie was ist
Aber es sind 30 minuten mega gehyped gewesen
So so ungefähr laufen gaming präsentationen heute ab und das klingt echt auf dem sack
Deswegen gucke ich mir den Kram nicht an. Ich gucke mir irgendwelche Zusammenfassungen an danach
Da weißt du besser da weiß na gut Battlefield 2042
Da musste wenigstens den lassen dass der Trailer gut war ja der Trailer genau das gezeigt hat was die Fans eigentlich sehen wollten
Natürlich hat man die Fans verarscht weil das eigentlich nicht so ist wie man es in den Trailer gezeigt hat
wenigstens hat man einen Trailer gehabt wo man was sieht ja und was die Leute irgendwie
Begründet gehyped gemacht hat
Dann sollen die Entwickler einfach erst was zeigen wenn es was sinnvolles zu zeigen gibt das ist ja das was ich meine wenn sich
Irgendwelche BWL Leute gedacht haben wir müssen jetzt mal das neue Game zeigen obwohl es eigentlich noch gar nichts zu zeigen gibt
Dann ist es halt bescheuert oder man macht es halt kurz und knackig ja erinnert euch noch in den Elder Scrolls 6 Trailer
der kein Trailer war der das Titel der das das Titel Titel Bild war Elder Scrolls 6 und
Und dann war fertig
30 Sekunden Trailer und dann war Ruhe okay kann man ja machen wenn man nichts zu zeigen hat aber was mir auf den Sack geht ist diese
20 30 Minuten das ist das geilste Game ever und wir sind alle so gehyped nur dass man halt nichts zeigt
oder das was man zeigt halt
offensichtlich nicht zum zeigen gedacht ist weil es ja nicht fertig ist ach keine Ahnung es ist bescheuert es ist
Es ist halt so wenn zu viel Marketing und BWL Leute dort die Entscheidung treffen
Erwähnst du bei deinen Bewerbungen YouTube oder Twitch ich habe keine Ahnung was meint ihr chat
sollte ich in meinem
Skill Skill Profil auf Xing mit aufnehmen dass ich Technik Streamer bin auf Twitch
Weil YouTube kann ich jetzt schlecht erwähnen oder
Ja genau das ganze vergessen
Kommt darauf an wie es ein Job das ist ein Job der definitiv nichts mit Streaming oder YouTube zu tun hat
Also ich würde es nicht in der Bewerbung würde ich es auf gar keinen Fall schreiben
Würde ich nicht machen die Flames zu viel aber das stimmt
Ja mache ich ist richtig
Ich also ich hatte nicht vor das reinzuschreiben und ich werde das auch nicht reinschreiben
Erstens ist dann die Verknüpfung zwischen meinem LinkedIn Profil und meinem Twitch und und YouTube zu einfach
Irgendjemand wird es eh finden bin ich mir sicher
Ja
Ich weiß nicht keine Ahnung so wir lassen uns jetzt wir lassen uns jetzt von Level Capture beenden
Mein Nachname ist Wubblors woher weißt du das
Gibt es eigentlich noch so eine Spalte für Hobbys im Lebenslauf keine Ahnung
Ich meine ich rede ja vom LinkedIn Profil keine Ahnung
Okay auf geht's
Das lassen wir uns bei Level Capture beenden fertig
Moment ich habe die Musik noch nicht ausgemacht oder doch habe ich
Design Director das haben die auch bitter nötig die ganzen designer von Battlefield sind abgehauen und die die da sind haben Battlefield 2042 verbrochen
Da würde ich auch ganz schnell nach neuen suchen wie wäre es denn ob ihr vielleicht welche bekommt die früher schon mal ein gutes Battlefield gemacht haben
Wobei die werden keinen Bock auf die land hat studio the director would oversee the production of a single-player campaign for a new
Battlefield game the right candidate should know what they're doing as EA is looking for someone with at least 10 years of experience
For now the Seattle studio is expected to expand the narrative side of the battlefield franchise
However, it's still in its infancy
It's unknown whether or not this single-player experience will be added to battlefield 2042 or if it'll be something im
Leben nicht wer glaubt denn allen Ernstes dass es noch nennenswerte Updates für 2042 gibt also
Entirely new in other news battlefield community manager Tom Stratman has confirmed that the devs are looking into balancing the MV 38 condors
The millimeter cannon pod we're looking to balance ok jetzt mal ernsthaft
Die wollen uns die wollen uns wirklich erzählen da arbeitet noch eine nennenswerte Mannschaft bei da ist dran ich kann es immer nur sagen entweder
Stimmt das nicht was sie sagt oder sie sind schlicht und ergreifend unfähig mein ernsthaft vor drei wochen oder so wann war das release
Und im monat vor einem monat
Also release vor einem monat und jetzt machen sie einen post dass sie die kennens tunen wollen
also
Sind die einfach nur unfähig und bohren den ganzen tag mit 150 leute dort in der nase oder sitzen da wirklich nur noch fünf leute
dran ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was ich
Besser oder schlechter finden soll also es gibt ja nur die möglichkeit zwischen ea lügt uns an
Oder da ist es komplett unfähig ich würde tatsächlich bevorzugen ea lügt uns an weil
da ist es komplett unfähig was man eigentlich am battlefield 2042 eigentlich schon denken müsste aber
also die
Die variante ea lügt uns an dass da noch so viele leute dran arbeiten ist mir lieber weil das mehr hoffnung für neue
in der zukunft vielleicht noch halbwegs passable battlefield games macht als umgedreht also ich mein guck mal
Es ist ein monat her und jetzt machen sie einen post wir werden das balancen also das ist auch wieder so
so typisch die leute sind doch schon wieder weg lasst mal kurz gucken sekunde
Die leute sind schon wieder fast weg hier das war mal 14.000 und jetzt wieder 600 das ist das ist wie gesagt in drei drei wochen oder
So ist das wieder vorher wie vorher das das hält die spieler auch klar gewesen dass die spieler nicht hält also ihr balancen jetzt wo alle schon wieder weg sind
Kilometer canon pod right now many players feel that this transport is way too strong against infantry and
Too tanky fans are happy to hear that balancing changes may be on their way
One user on steam claims call of duty modern warfare 2 will utilize valves steam workshop the user another giveaway
Claims they received a notification in steam telling them modern warfare 2 would be part of the steam workshop
This would allow users to mod the game and create content for it offering this freedom to players. Da bin ich mal gespannt
Das wäre richtig clever von denen wenn es ordentliches modding für modern warfare gebe für modern warfare 2
Die werden es aber wahrscheinlich beschränken was du modden kannst weil ansonsten ist die frage warum sollten sich die leute das nächste call of duty kaufen
Aber es wäre also das wäre ein wirklich guter modding für modern warfare 2
Aber es wäre also das wäre ein wirklich guter zug weil alle spiele die ich kenne die lange überlebt haben liegt es dann
Oder alle ist jetzt übertrieben aber sagen wir die meisten spiele die ich kenne die lange überlegt
Überlebt haben und lange zeit spieler base hatten und spieler hatten lag an modding
Guckt euch skyrim an warum spielen die leute heute noch skyrim weil mods guckt euch an warum spielen die leute heute teilweise noch half life 1
weil mods
Blende auch mords die leute spielen heute mehr e relink to the past als 1993
Weil random because mods wobei das nicht wirklich mord im eigentlichen sind das ist nichts was nintendo jemals
Geplant hat ja
emparte mod doch die mz đã schonъ
Hab dir schon mal einen
ähm, geplant hat, ja.
Habt ihr schon mal einen, ähm, A Link to the Past Randomizer geguckt?
Die meisten kennen das wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Ich meine, A Link to the Past kennt ihr wahrscheinlich.
Das ist das, ähm, das ist das Super Nintendo Cellar Spiel.
Das da.
Bilder hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal gesehen.
Also halt die.
Also mit, mit eines der bekanntesten Super Nintendo Spiele überhaupt.
Zumindest.
Es gibt einen Emulator, Mod, beziehungsweise stimmt nicht.
Ein, ein ROM.
Ein ROM Generator.
Oder ein ROM Patcher, besser gesagt.
Ein ROM Patcher.
Für, äh, für den Emulator.
Der das ganze Spiel randomized.
Also der randomized die Location der Items.
Der randomized teilweise die Location der Schlüssel.
Der randomized die Location des, sogar von Bossgegnern.
Es gibt da verschiedene Staffelungen.
Wie randomized das Spiel ist.
Es ist aber, und das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Weil du kannst dieses Spiel nicht durchspielen.
Mit komplett randomizedem Inhalt.
Weil dann würdest du Items quasi erst dann finden.
Wenn du sie schon gebraucht hättest.
Das heißt, der randomizer hat eine Logik drinne.
Sodass das Spiel randomized wird.
Aber immer noch durchspielbar ist.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Wie man sich das jetzt im Anfang vorstellt.
So nach dem Motto, einfach jede Kiste random und gut ist.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das Spiel braucht die Items schon in gewisser Reihenfolge.
Weil du sonst nicht durchspielen kannst.
Und das ist ziemlich, ziemlich big brain.
Und das ist recht beliebt auf Twitch.
Also wenn ihr rumguckt.
Es gibt jeden Tag Runs, Turniere für A Link to the Past Randomizer.
Also wir können eigentlich davon ausgehen.
Umso mehr was die Neid wird, umso wahrscheinlicher ist es.
Also ich will ja nichts sagen, aber es sieht aus wie Crysis.
Gut, ich meine, wir wissen warum.
Aber es sieht schon hart aus wie Crysis.
Also wenn du eine Waffe hast und durch solche Szenen läufst, sieht es hart aus wie Crysis.
Ansonsten nicht.
Guck, da haben wir sie wieder.
Die Twitter empörten sind am Start.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen.
EA Posted, EA Posted Müll.
Die Leute regen sich da drüber auf.
Okay, soweit, okay.
Ist eigentlich schon immer so gewesen.
Irgendwer erzählt kacke, Leute regen sich drüber auf.
Was heute noch dazu gekommen ist, dass Leute sich über alle Maßen aufregen.
Mir geht es jetzt nicht um diesen Tweet ganz im Speziellen.
Also jemand postet oder sagt Scheiße und Leute sagen es ist kacke, dass du sowas erzählst und du bist nix falsch und was auch immer.
Also einer erzählt Mist, Leute regen sich drüber auf, dass er Mist erzählt hat.
Soweit, so normal.
Aber auf Twitter wird sich über alle Maßen empört.
Also weit oftmals über das hinaus, was irgendwie noch noch erklärbar ist.
So nach dem Motto EA Posted Müll und anstatt zu schreiben null kacke Firma oder sowas wird dann irgendwie was geschrieben so wegen euch ist meine Oma gestorben oder sowas.
Die reden total am Rat teilweise.
Also Twitter Empörung ist nicht immer normal.
Also die Leute regen sich erstens über alle Maßen auf über Dinge, wo es komplett unverhältnismäßig ist.
Und das zweite ist, was mich genauso nervt, dass dann immer so dieses wir müssen uns für jeden Scheiß entschuldigen kommt.
So nach dem Motto Oh, wir haben irgendwo wir haben Mist gepostet. Es tut uns so leid. Wir werden in Zukunft versuchen, uns zu verbessern.
Oder nee, das ist zu milde ausgedrückt.
Die schreiben das immer. Die schreiben das immer so richtig so richtig übertrieben.
Wir sind wir sind jetzt bessere Menschen.
So nach dem Motto Sowas wird in Zukunft nicht mehr vorkommen.
Uns ist bewusst, dass wir sehr viele Menschen schwer verletzt haben durch unsere Worte und werden in Zukunft alles besser machen.
So, wisst ihr, so dieses super krasse, also dieses super krasse mega entschuldigen ist auch.
Ich meine, warum kann es nicht einfach so sein?
Jemand postet Müll.
Die Leute schreiben, ey, das ist Müll.
Und wisst ihr was? Dann ist gut.
Warum kann es nicht einfach so bleiben?
Müll, man sagt, es ist Müll, es ist Kacke, was auch immer. Dann ist gut.
Dann nächstes Thema, please.
Da muss man keine fünf Tage drauf rumreiten.
Und ich brauche auch keine zweiseitige Entschuldigung, die man ihm eh nicht abnimmt.
Es gibt ja durchaus Sachen, wo das angebracht ist.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich glaube manchmal?
Ich glaube, die haben für jeden Tweet, den sie machen mittlerweile, schon einen passenden Entschuldigungspost vorbereitet.
Und was meint ihr? Wie realistisch ist meine Einschätzung?
Also ich glaube, das ist nicht so weit weg von der Realität.
Die Leute wissen doch im Vorfeld schon, also wenn es gescheite Marketingleute sind,
die wissen doch im Vorfeld schon, welche Posts einen gewissen Kontroversitätsfaktor haben.
Oder welche Tweets wahrscheinlich in falschen Hals bekommen werden können.
Und die haben für solche Tweets im Vorfeld garantiert vorgefertigte Entschuldigung schon am Start.
Ja gut, warum die das als später releasen, das weiß ich nicht.
Also mich würde es wundern, wenn das, ich sage nicht für jeden Tweet, ja ich weiß, ich habe vor fünf Minuten gesagt,
es war nicht so gemeint, also nicht für jeden, absolut jeden Post, den die machen,
aber für Posts, wo sich die Marketingabteilung denkt, oh das könnte eventuell kontrovers aufgenommen werden,
haben die schon einen passenden, mit dem Entschuldigungs, mit dem Apology Generator generierte Entschuldigungsmeldung,
die sie im Zweifelsfall dann auch am Wochenende über irgendeinen vorgefertigten Twitter-Bot raushauen können.
Bestimmt, bestimmt, die haben garantiert schon was vorgefertigtes.
Weil du musst ja heute davon ausgehen, dass potentiell jeder Twitter-Post einen riesigen Shitstorm produzieren kann.
Jeder, jeder Twitter-Post.
Weil so auf aktuellen Stand kannst du auch als Marketing-Mensch nicht sein, dass du das alles überschauen kannst.
Du kannst deine Tweets schon einschätzen oder deine Community-Posts sicherlich schon einschätzen, so wie kontrovers könnten die aufgenommen werden,
aber du kannst ja gar nicht alles vorfeld wissen.
Ich meine heute ist, guck mal, heute ist beispielsweise das Wort Roast noch okay, vielleicht ist das Wort morgen absolut verpönt
und du hast es noch nicht mitbekommen und benutzt das Wort Roast und bist auf einmal quasi ganz, ganz böse.
Weil du das Wort Roast verwendet hast, obwohl du gar nicht weißt, dass es jetzt böse ist.
Das kann ja auf Twitter immer passieren.
Weiter.
Ist das... soll das Isaac sein? Isaac sieht aber...
Der sah anders aus in Dead Space.
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz cool in Dead Space 1.
Man hat ja nie das Gesicht von ihm gesehen, außer zum Schluss, woran diese Maske abgenommen hat.
Okay Leute, ich habe verstanden.
Also von euch aus dem Chat weiß ich, Apex ist wohl mobile tatsächlich ganz okay.
Entgegen meinen Erwartungen.
Zumindest hat mir das der Chat letzte Woche erzählt, das muss ganz, ganz brauchbar sein.
Ich kann es mir zwar immer noch nicht vorstellen, wie man gerade Apex, was ja schon ein relativ schnelles Game ist,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise gescheit mit dem Touchscreen spielen können soll, aber anscheinend geht das ja.
Oder die Leute cheaten alle, indem sie irgendwelche Plutus... was heißt cheaten?
Das ist ja okay, aber irgendwelche Plutus-Controller anschließen, äh, oder Wiredes-Controller oder irgendwelche Controller anschließen und damit spielen.
Ich komme auch mit Touchscreen. Ich kam schon auf dem Nintendo DS mit Touchscreen-Steuerung, nicht klar.
Verkommt er Geld dafür?
Nee, das ist nicht Sponsort, das ist nicht Sponsort.
By the way, bei diesem Trailer, wir reden hier von Gaming-Hardware, was auch immer das mit Gaming-Hardware zu tun hat, was wir da sehen. Also das ist, ich meine, die sind so in-game mit dieser neuen Gaming-Hardware, das ist dann so, aber, ich meine, wie wäre es denn, einfach mal Gaming-Hardware zu zeigen bzw. die Specks zu verraten?
Reden die beim Noise-Canceling vom Mikro? Ich hoffe nicht. Die reden vom Kopfhörer-Anteil des Headsets. Reden die vom Noise-Canceling. Das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt. Das kann Sony ziemlich gut.
Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer. Warum man jetzt wirklich bei einem Gaming-Kopfhörer Noise-Canceling braucht, ich bin mir unschlüssig. Ich meine, Games spielst du jetzt nicht unbedingt auf der Baustelle und die Games haben einen gewissen Sound.
Und du kannst doch einfach einen geschlossenen Kopfhörer nehmen, wie beispielsweise das MMX300, also geschlossenes Headset. Da kriegst du weniger von drum und rum mit. Und der Game-Sound reicht, dass du sonst gar nichts mehr mitbekommst.
Was ich persönlich angenehmer finde als Noise-Canceling, also ich mag es nicht den ganzen Tag Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer aufzuhaben, weil der Unterschied ist Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer.
Vielleicht kennen ihr das? Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer erzeugen bei mir das Gefühl von Druck auf den Ohren.
Weil das ja durch irgendwie so... Also Noise-Canceling funktioniert ja dadurch, dass sich Schallenwellen irgendwie so auscanceln oder so.
Das ist, du hast Druckgefühl auf den Ohren mit Noise-Canceling. Also ich zumindest habe Druckgefühl auf den Ohren bei Noise-Canceling.
Ich habe irgendwelche... Irgendwas von Bose, auch wenn ich kein großer Bose-Fan bin, aber die waren damals ziemlich gut. Laut Tests und Reviews irgendwelche 50...
Nee, wie heißen die Dinger? Keine Ahnung. Müsste ich jetzt immer... Moment, ich guck mal im Amazon. QC35, das klingt ganz gut, ja.
Aber ich hab die schon ein paar Jahre, also je nachdem wie alt die sind. Moment, ich guck mal kurz in mein Amazon.
Bose. Oh, mein Headset brummt, weil ich mein Handy in der Hand hab. Toll. QuietComfort 35, kabellose Kopfdings, Bluetooth-Kopfhörer. Hab ich.
Ja, also da hab ich Druck auf den Ohren, das finde ich nicht so gut. Das ist super in der Bahn oder so. Okay, wenn das bei Sony nicht so ist, dann...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, was ich auch noch sagen muss. Also ich hab ja mit meinen geschlossenen MMX300 schon ab und zu Probleme, dass ich nichts höre drum herum. Ich persönlich finde es gerade, wenn man nicht komplett alleine im Haushalt ist, gar nicht verkehrt, wenn man trotz Gaming noch was von der Umwelt mitbekommt.
Also das, was ich hier erkläre.
Was finde ich?
Diese Aussage finde ich auch immer wieder geil. Studios resources are used elsewhere. Also ich halte mal fest, ein Spiel, was sie als Service-Game released haben, was zum Release weniger Content hatte als die Teile davor, ein Spiel, was laut vielen Halo-Fans eh schon zu wünschen übrig lässt was das Halo-Feeling angeht.
Aber was als Service-Game angelegt ist...
Und jetzt einen...
Ich weiß es nicht, wie Gamebreaking-Bug das ist, hat.
Sagt, ihr Service-Game kann nicht gepatcht werden so schnell, weil die Ressourcen anderswo verplant sind oder was.
Was ist denn der Sinn von einem Service-Game, wenn man das Service-Game nicht servicegemäß servicepatchen kann?
Ja genau, ich meine gerade, wenn du sagst, es ist ein Service-Game, wo ist denn der Service bei diesem Service-Game?
Wenn wirklich kritische Bugs sind, dann ist es ein Service-Game.
Du kannst ja nicht beides haben wollen, du kannst nicht sagen, Service-Game, kauft euch Skins oder so.
Aber wie, Game ist kaputt, nö, das fixen wir nicht. Aber kauft euch mal weiter, Skins.
War das nicht so in den ersten Spielen?
Und war das nicht so, ich hab das nie gespielt, das Zeug von denen, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich kenne das aus ein paar Reddit-Posts und News-Posts.
Hab ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung, dass die Games, die hatten ja vorher dieses, also die hatten ja ganz am Anfang ihr eigenes Game.
Ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt, das mit Portalen und so. Weiß noch jemand, wie das hieß?
Das haben bei mir auf der Arbeit damals auch total viele Leute auf dem Handy gespielt.
Ich nicht, sowas mit Portale-Captchern und sowas. Ich hab vergessen, wie das hieß.
Ist es Ingress, genau das meine ich. Ist es nicht so, dass Ingress, Pokemon Go und das Harry Potter-Game quasi mehr oder weniger exakt die gleiche Datenbasis verwendet an Locations und Maps und Orten.
Und nur so dieses, dieser Story-Layer quasi oben drüber daraus andere Games macht. Also bei dem einen ist es halt Pokemon, bei dem anderen ist es halt Harry Potter-Welt, bei dem anderen ist es irgendeine Science-Fiction-Welt.
Anderes geht genauso, mein ich das. Das hat mich ja auch ein bisschen abgeschreckt.
Naja, in dem Fall ist es ja nicht so, dass nur einer wohl jammert mit dem Bug gefixt werden will.
Es ist ja wohl so, dass Halo gerade im Competitive Bereich, und das ist ja ein wichtiger großes Ding bei Halo, wohl kaum richtig spielbar ist. Also scheint schon ein größeres Problem zu sein.
Und bei einem Service-Game zu sagen, ja das können wir gerade nicht fixen, weil die Ressourcen nicht da sind, wo ist denn der Service?
Und das war's für heute. Ich hoffe, ihr habt es genossen. Bis zum nächsten Mal, das war Levelcap, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das ist Paying as a Service. Jim, das reicht ja. Ich mein, wozu überhaupt noch Spiele und Content entwickeln? Einfach PaaS, nee PaaS gibt's schon, das ist Platform-as-a-Service, Paying as a Service einführen.
Da müssten sie ja gar nicht. Es spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, die gleichen Daten wieder zu verwenden, aber das scheint ja nicht so richtig funktioniert zu haben. Die Leute haben Pokémon gefeiert, höchstwahrscheinlich, weil sie Ingress vorher nicht gespielt haben.
Und die Leute haben wahrscheinlich relativ schnell festgestellt, dass das Harry-Potter-Game ein Pokémon Go-Clone ist. Dann hast du dann halt kein Stadion, oder dann kannst du halt dort nichts Captchern, sondern hast irgendwie einen Zauberstab an der gleichen Stelle.
Und weil Pokémon quasi das Wichtigste der Welt ist, was markentechnisch angeht, scheint er nicht funktioniert zu haben.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Hier, zeig mal hier. Der schnellste Putzroboter der Welt. Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken. Zeig mal her. Angeblich bis zu 60 Stundenkilometer schnell. Stand im Thumbnail, guckt hier.
Das hier ist ein normaler... Ja, irgendwo, irgendwo. Moment. Trick 17, wenn man sich das Thumbnail angucken will, einfach in Firefox aufmachen, weil Firefox habe ich Autoplay aus.
Excellent.
You are signed out. Oh nein.
Der schnellste Putzroboter der Welt. Auf geht's.
Sag mal, ich habe in meinem Vorschau-Video Frametrops, aber hier habe ich keine Frametrops, oder? Oder hatte ich eben Frametrops?
Vodafone, was ist da los?
Das hier ist ein normaler Putzroboter.
Und das ist mein Putzroboter.
MonkaS. RGB. Kein Wunder, dass der so schnell ist.
Jetzt ist klar. Das ist der Trick.
In diesem Video zeige ich euch, wie ich ihn entwickelt und gebaut habe und wie er funktioniert.
Staubsauger-Roboter sind toll, aber einen Fehler machen alle Firmen, die sie verkaufen.
Und zwar bauen sie extrem langsam und langweilig. Was soll ich denn machen, wenn in 20 Minuten mein Tinder-Dell vor der Tür steht und die Wohnung sieht aus wie Sau?
Dann bin ich ziemlich aufgeschmissen. Und um diese Marktlücke zu schließen, werde ich jetzt einen Putzroboter entwickeln, der sicker und schneller ist als alles, was man bis jetzt auf dem Markt kaufen kann.
Um einen superschnellen Putzroboter zu bauen...
Wisst ihr, was das Problem bei schnellen Putzrobotern ist? Die sind wahrscheinlich nicht gleichermaßen gründlich.
Weil stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt jetzt einen Boden, wo Dreck drauf ist.
Und dann kommt der Putzroboter und dann fährt er langsam drüber. Dann kann er das alles aufnehmen.
Wenn der Putzroboter einfach... dann hat er halt nicht genug Zeit, den ganzen Müll aufzusaugen.
Max, kannst du ein How-to-Clickbait-Video machen? Nee, ich kann keinen guten Clickbait.
Man kann verstehen, wie ein normaler Putzroboter überhaupt funktioniert.
Normale Saugroboter haben meistens ein rundes Gehäuse, zwei angetriebene Räder, zwei Würste vorne...
Er saugt halt!
Dann haben sie meistens einen Saugmechanismus und einen Schmutzfangbehälter und einen Akku.
Und natürlich noch die Elektronik, die alles steuert.
Für unseren Putzroboter müssen wir diese Architektur ein bisschen anpassen, weil unser Fokus liegt auf dem maximalen Speed.
Unser Roboter kriegt natürlich erst mal größere Reifen für mehr Grip.
So, dass er weiter von der Erde weg ist und noch schlechter saugt?
Natürlich auch die Motoren größer werden für mehr Power. Die brauchen natürlich eine größere Batterie, weil das alles mit Strom versorgt werden muss.
Und die Elektronik wird leider auch ein bisschen größer, weil ich die nicht so klein bauen kann, wie die Hersteller.
Ihr merkt schon, der ganze Staubsaugmechanismus musste leider weichen, aber der Fokus liegt ja ganz klar auf dem...
Wait a minute! Der saugt jetzt gar nicht mehr! Okay, einfach nur Just For Fun das Ding, so wie es aussieht.
Ein Staubsauger habe ich eh schon! Ja, das ist gut, das stimmt!
Ich habe auch einen Staubsauger. Einen ganz normalen Staubsauger.
Aluminiumplatte aufgebaut, darauf sind die Motoren und Achsen befestigt und der Rest ist der Technik. Drumherum kommt natürlich noch ein neues.
Ich meine, da könnte man sich einfach ein ferngesteuertes Auto kaufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich noch schneller.
Und es sieht dann halt nicht aus, wie ein Staubsaugerroboter, der keiner ist.
Und die Räder dran. Zuerst habe ich die Aluminiumplatte bearbeitet.
Ich meine, das Projekt an sich mag schon cool sein. Sinnhaft ist es nicht.
Da muss ja nicht immer alles sinnvoll sein. Wir machen auch genug unsinnige Sachen im Stream.
Gerade keine CNC-Fräse da hat, dann kann man das so machen, indem man einfach seinen Plan aufbaut.
Das ist kein Wischroboter, das ist ein wahrscheinlich mit nassem Lappen-Dreck-Verteilroboter am Ende.
Und auf das Aluminium aufklebt. Die Löcher kann man dann einfach bohren.
Und die größeren Löcher habe ich ganz einfach mit einer Stichsäge ausgesägt.
Dann habe ich noch den Rest der Teil 3D gedruckt und das ganze Teil zusammengebaut.
Das ganze rumgeschraubt ist langweilig. Ich zeige euch einfach, wie sick das fertige Teil geworden ist.
Bevor ich euch jetzt zeige, wie das Teil fährt, erkläre ich euch erstmal meine geniale Konstruktion.
Und zwar ist es eigentlich recht simpel. Die Reifen werden über zwei Motoren und Zahnräden und ein paar 3D gedruckte Teile angetrieben.
Dann ist im hinteren Teil die ganze Elektronik mit dem Akku verbaut.
Also wie lang die 3D gedruckten Zahnräder halten, das wird mich tatsächlich interessieren.
Die halten sicherlich erstmal, aber ich glaube, die sind nicht langzeit-einsatzfähig.
Dann ist unten ein Lappen dran, der wird über so einen Magnet-Clip hingemacht, dass man ihn einfach wechseln kann.
Das wird eindeutig ein, ich verteile meinen Dreck ein bisschen auf den Boden, Rumschieberoboter.
Eine kleine Pumpe, über die ihr Putzmittel auf den Boden verteilen kann, damit er auch wirklich putzen kann.
Gesteuert wird das ganze mit meinem Smartphone, da habe ich eine Applikation drauf.
Über die kann ich die Geschwindigkeit einstellen und starten und stoppen.
Und der Roboter zeigt mir mit seinem LED-Ring an, wie schnell er gerade ist.
Zum Beispiel das, das ist gerade zum Beispiel halb.
Das muss sein.
Jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt, wie man den Roboter lenkt.
Und die Antwort darauf ist ganz einfach, und zwar die Antwort ist gar nicht, sondern er lenkt sich selber.
Es hat in der Vergangenheit schließlich immer super geklappt, wenn ich autonome Fahrzeuge gebaut habe.
Boah, der war nicht so krach, Alter.
Roboter fahren kann, da fehlt nur noch eine Sache, und zwar der Code.
Aber keine Angst, den zeige ich euch diesmal nicht komplett, sondern ich zeige euch nur den Part, wo ich verkackt habe.
Und zwar habe ich anfangs nämlich gedacht, dass nur ein einziger Sensor vorne ausreicht, um den ganzen Roboter zu steuern.
Das ist wie immer der erste Fahrttest.
Ich hoffe, dass er nicht gegen die Wand kracht.
Nicht gegen die Wand krachen.
Test Nummer 2.
Vielleicht brauchen wir doch mehr als nur einen Sensor.
Nachdem die ersten Tests nicht ganz so gut geklappt haben, habe ich dem Roboter noch mal zwei weitere Sensoren gegeben und den Code noch mal komplett überarbeitet.
Guter Ultraschall-Sensor.
SSCH4?
Nee, wie heißt das Ding?
HC4?
Da habe ich auch ein paar von da.
Also ich habe auch ein paar von da.
HC4? Da habe ich auch ein paar von da.
Weiß jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht, wie die heißen.
Das sind so Ultraschall-Abstands-Mess-Sensoren.
Noch mal komplett überarbeitet.
Der Roboter weiß jetzt immer genau, wie schnell er fährt und fängt dementsprechend früher an zu bremsen, wenn er gerade schneller fährt.
Er misst immer die Abstände nach vorne, nach rechts und nach links.
Was hat er für einen 3D-Drucker?
Hey, gleich ein 3D-Drucker wie ich!
Vorne, nach rechts und nach links.
Und wenn er nahe genug an die Wand kommt, dann fängt er an zu bremsen oder eben abzudrehen und zwar immer in die Richtung, in die gerade mehr Platz ist.
Und jetzt ist es Zeit, das zu testen.
Bisschen Fine-Tuning ist da angesagt.
Programmieren ist einfach so ein Scheiß.
Und zwar, wie ihr gerade gesehen habt, hat das Ding ja nicht so wirklich funktioniert, sondern ist immer rechts gegen die Wand gefahren.
Und dann habe ich nach ewig, wirklich ewig langem Suchen entdeckt, warum es so ist.
Und zwar habe ich hier in meinem Code, mach es scharf, komm, eine Klammer vergessen bei genau dieser Stelle hier.
Und deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert.
Und dieser Code, wow, wow, wow, nicht so schnell.
Beim Cutten von dem Video ist mir aufgefallen, dass ihr gar nicht verstehen könnt, wie der Code funktioniert, weil ich euch ihn nicht ausführlich genug gezeigt habe.
Und das werden wir jetzt ändern.
Hier oben sind erstmal die ganzen Bibliotheken, die wir brauchen.
Die sind langweilig.
Deswegen scrollen wir an den Teil, wo...
Also sozusagen ergibt sich wirklich sehr viel Mühe mit dem Video.
Also das ist nicht so was, was man mal kurz in 20 Minuten aufgenommen hat und geschnitten hat.
Hier werden die einzelnen Abstände gemessen von den Ultraschall-Sensoren.
Diese werden dann in den Variable Distance Centimeter, Distance Centimeter R und Distance Centimeter L.
Ach, wie nice ich immer so Arduino Zeug finde.
Delay, Delay, Delay, Delay, Delay.
Den rechten und den linken Sensor abgespeichert.
Der nächste Schritt wird in dieser Formel hier aus den Abständen in Abhängigkeit von der Geschwindigkeit, die unter der Variable Gas abgespeichert wurde, berechnet, wie der Bremsabstand in Abhängigkeit von der Geschwindigkeit eingestellt werden soll.
Das heißt, über dem Bruchstrich steht hier Distance Centimeter und unten drunter steht eben die Variable der Geschwindigkeit mal einen Vorfaktor plus eine voreingestellte Distanz.
Und da ich eben hier diese Klammer vergessen habe, Punkt vor Strich, ist der Wert größer.
Der wird im anschließenden Fall dann verglichen mit einem fixen Wert und wenn der unter diesem Wert schreitet, dann wird eben die Bremse angefangen zu lenken.
Und wie ihr gesehen, weil ich die Klammer vergessen habe, ist der Wert bei Distance Centimeter L größer gewesen.
Das heißt, es trifft später ein und das heißt, er fährt gegen die Wand.
Abmahnung ist raus.
Bei einer engeren Distanz.
Und genau das war das Problem und das habe ich jetzt gelöst.
Und jetzt sollte es funktionieren.
So, wir testen es erstmal auf der langsamsten Geschwindigkeit, auf der er gerade so fährt.
Ah, sieht gut aus.
Na, nicht schlecht.
Nicht schlecht.
Kann schon mal klappern, das Ding.
Nach der Gefahr, dass es klappt, war es auch in der Zeit, das Putzen zu testen.
Und den Lappen dahin zu machen, legt man einfach diesen Magnetstreifen auf den Boden und den Lappen so drüber.
So.
Und da.
Ehrlich gesagt, Leute, Chet, mir fällt gar nichts anderes ein, als das mit einem Delay zu machen in der Stelle.
Ich meine, wenn du irgendwelche Motorsachen steuerst oder so, ich meine, es hat ja auch keinen Sinn, das irgendwie asynchrot zu machen oder so.
Du willst halt wirklich, was weiß ich, kleiner Impuls dann, 10 Millisekunden, Mikrosekunden waren, nächster Impuls da.
Also, das ist halt nur halt synchron, ja.
Weiß nicht, ich glaube, das ist, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist schlimm.
Ich habe das nur auch schon öfters gemerkt, dass du halt gerade was Microcontroller-Sachen angehst,
halt sau oft irgendwelche Sleeps einbauen musst, dass es funktioniert im Vergleich zu, wenn du irgendwelche Desktop-Sachen machst,
wo du halt möglichst das Ganze asynchron machen sollst.
Das liegt aber auch im Desktop-Bereich daran, weil du dort mehrere Threads hast, was sich beim Arduino halt gar nicht juckt.
Ja, die machen das bestimmt nicht über Interrupts.
Die machen das bestimmt nicht über Interrupts.
Ja, in Interrupt-Funktionen darfst du nicht sleepen, das ist klar.
Das ist alles in der Main-Schleife drin, da kannst du sleepen, wie du lustig bist.
Und dann kann ich einfach so draufsetzen und zack, ist er hier unten festgekripst.
Nice. Und jetzt kann er putzen. Let's go.
Das ist cool.
Ich meine, der Roboter ist komplett unsinnig, der macht nichts Sinnvolles, aber es ist cool, sowas selbst zu bauen, das ist nicht ohne.
Genug funktioniert, ich denke, wir können ein bisschen mehr Speed geben.
Ja, gib ihm.
40, mal schauen, was passiert.
Nee, der fährt kein richtiges Paddern, der fährt geradeaus, bis er an ein Hindernis kommt und dann dreht er so, dass er nicht mehr ans Hindernis kommt.
Und dann fährt er in die Richtung weiter geradeaus, bis das nächste Hindernis kommt und dreht.
So, in der Richtung wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass er mit sowas Probleme hat, guckt mal hier.
Mit solchen Dingern, mit solchen Dingern, kann ich mir vorstellen, hat das Ding Probleme.
Wenn das hier lang fährt, ich meine, das kommt nur an einem Sensor quasi ins Blickfeld und auch so, dass es nur ganz knapp streifen würde.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es knallt manchmal immer noch.
Ich denke, es ist Zeit mal ein bisschen mehr.
Nee, rund ist für die Sensoren viel besser.
Rund ist für die Sensoren deutlich besser, weil wenn du es eckig hast, dann hast du einen, also wenn du, guckt mal.
Also du hast jetzt hier deinen Staubsauger-Roboter eckig.
So, dann kannst du hier einen Sensor hinmachen.
Dann kannst du hier einen Sensor hinmachen, da einen Sensor hinmachen und da einen Sensor hinmachen.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dieser Sensor kann nicht da hingucken und dieser Sensor kann nicht wirklich da.
Also der maximale Sichtradius von diesem Sensor wird sowas hier sein.
Was blöd ist, wenn du das rund hast, wenn du das rund hast, dann kannst du die, nein, oh Gott, Paint.
Wenn du das rund hast, dann kannst du die Sensoren nämlich so bauen, dass du, so, so, so, so, so, so.
Und dann hast du mehrere Sensoren, die den gleichen Bereich teilweise abdecken können.
Na gut, denn nach hinten geht das nicht, es geht eher so.
Da hast du deutlich bessere Möglichkeiten zu erkennen, wenn was ab, wenn was ins Feld reinkommt.
Also es ist viel genauer.
Was bestimmt einer der Gründe ist, warum Staubsauger-Roboter tatsächlich rund sind.
Und wahrscheinlich auch, weil du, ich stelle mir auch schwierig, wie du fahren willst eckig.
Weil du würdest zwar theoretisch besser in Ecken passen, aber du könntest ja dann, du müsstest ja dann quasi in die Ecke reinfahren.
Und dann müsstest du zurückfahren, soweit, dass du wieder drehen kannst.
Ich stelle es mir tatsächlich so deutlich einfacher vor.
Speed auf super, obwohl das eigentlich schon zu schnell für die Wohnung ist, aber wir gehen auf 70. Mal schauen, was passiert ist.
Wow, wow, wow.
Die maximale Geschwindigkeit hier in der Wohnung werde ich nicht testen, da es einfach viel zu klein ist. Der Roboter hat immer angefangen, sich einfach nur nach rechts zu drehen, weil er gesehen hat, dass die Abstände zu eng sind.
Und deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert. Vielleicht finde ich noch eine größere Location. Wenn ja, mache ich dann vielleicht ein TikTok-Video drüber, das sieht ihr dann auf meinem TikTok-Kanal.
Danke fürs Zuschauen. Tschau.
Es ist wirklich cooles Projekt, hat zwar keinerlei sinnvollen Nutzbarkeitsfaktor, aber coole Sache.
Zu wenig RGB. Ja komm, da war schon schnell genug, noch mehr RGB konnte er nicht handeln.
Zu Will69, danke für den Sub.
Also, ihn muss man ja mal eins lassen. Der hat die Clickbait-Titel auch durchgespielt.
Der hat teilweise solche abgedrehten Titel, die nichts mit dem Inhalt zu tun haben, ist der Wahnsinn.
Sieben nützliche CMD-Befehle. Oh ne, CMD. Wenn ich CMD lese, habe ich schon keinerlei Bock, mir das anzugucken.
Schon das gesehen? Nee. Die nicht mal Microsoft kennt, ja.
Was der Aufstieg und Fall von OnePlus. Gab es da einen Fall, Leute?
Ich habe bei Android-Geräten keinen Plan. Ist das nicht immer noch relativ beliebt?
Was, das Aimbot-Video? Welches war das? Ach, der Typ, der seine Maus mit einem Motor hatte, oder?
Aimbots is evolving. Ja, dass sowas gibt, wundert mich jetzt so wirklich nicht.
Das Schwierige daran ist aber, den Input zu bekommen. Also, wie schaffst du es aus dem Spiel, was auszulesen und darauf zu reagieren?
Aber wir reden in einer Sekunde mehr darüber. Zuerst habe ich eine Frage für dich.
Warum gibt es immer noch so viele Aimbot-Cheaters in First-Person-Shootern,
nach all den Verbesserungen, die wir in der Anti-Cheat-Technologie hatten?
Mit Colonel-Mode-Treibern und allem hast du nicht gesehen.
Also, was da für Geschütze aufgefahren werden, mittlerweile Anti-Cheat-technisch, ist schon heftig.
Und das war aber schon immer ein Katze- und Maus-Spiel zwischen Cheating-Entwicklern und Anti-Cheat.
Auf Konsole kümmert es keinen, wenn du natürlich kümmert das auf Konsole jemanden. Warum soll es dort keinen kümmern?
Versuch mal beispielsweise auf der Xbox, Modern Warfare 2 oder Black Ops oder sonst was zu spielen.
Und das noch vor ein paar Jahren, konntest du vergessen. Modern Lobbies ohne Ende.
Negatives Boosting, sodass du alle Unlocks verlierst. Das war voll für'n Arsch.
Natürlich stört das jemand.
Aber man muss sagen, auf dem PC liegt es halt einfach daran, weil der PC eine offene Plattform ist.
Das ist so. Mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen.
Du kannst auf deinem PC prinzipiell machen, was du willst. Auf der Konsole nicht.
Dementsprechend ist es mit Cheats auf dem PC natürlich einfacher.
Du kannst auf deinem PC prinzipiell machen, was du willst. Auf der Konsole nicht. Dementsprechend ist es mit Cheats auf dem PC natürlich einfacher.
Das ist ein bisschen einfacher, einen Einbock zu tun, um die simplistischen Anti-Cheat-Mechaniken zu verhelfen,
und den Spieler eine unfaire Vorteile zu geben.
Und so ist die Art, wie Anti-Cheats funktionieren, weniger um die Analyse der Spieler-Inputs,
sondern um die wissliche Software-Aktivität, die im Spiel passiert ist.
Die sehr einfachen Explanationen, wie Einbocks funktionieren, sind, dass sie Daten,
z.B. die Location der Kopf der Gegner, aus deinem Systemes Erinnern, während das Spiel läuft.
Wenn du einen Angriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher hast,
und über den Arbeitsspeicher dann Sachen aus dem Game auslesen,
das Game denkt, es wäre eine Netzwerkkarte,
und das darum wieder weitergeben, dann z.B. an irgendwelche hardwaregemordeten Mäuse,
oder Controller in hardwaregemordeten Mäusen,
die dann auslösen, sobald du mit der Maus über den Kopf des Gegners gehst.
Das ist mittlerweile wirklich krasser Five-Head-Shit.
Du kannst es dann an bestimmte Locations anzeigen, um deinen Kopf zu beenden.
An der Anti-Cheats-Seite werden modernen Anti-Cheats allsortsen Dinge tun,
wie das Monitoren deiner Erinnerung, das Schauen deiner Computerfile und mehr,
um zu versuchen, eine wissliche Aktivität auf deinem System zu entdecken und dich zu verbreiten.
Und über die Jahre sind beide Cheats und Anti-Cheats in einem endlosen Armwesen geschlossen,
die mehr und mehr sophisticated Methoden verwendet sind, um den anderen zu verschleißen.
Aber es scheint, dass die Cheater letztlich gewinnen können, weil jetzt...
Was ist der Sinn darin?
Der Sinn darin ist, dass es der gleiche Sinn oder Unsinn wie Cheaten im Allgemeinen,
nur jetzt halt auf eine etwas modernere Art und Weise.
Also die Frage ist eigentlich, was ist der Sinn im Cheaten?
Den kann ich euch nicht beantworten.
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen? Ich hab damals auch gecheatet, aber nicht in CS, sondern in DAOG.
Ich hab Radar-Hack gehabt.
Und zwar, das war so, dass man, wenn man durch PVP-Gebiet gelaufen ist,
dass man halt früher wusste, wo Gegner sind.
Und das Spiel war halt nicht darauf ausgelegt, dagegen irgendwie geschützt zu sein.
Und zwar, das war nix verschlüsselt, das war alles Klartexts, UDP-Packages.
Und was ich damals gemacht hab, ist, also die haben natürlich selbstverständlich
schon im Hintergrund versucht zu detekten, ob du Cheating-Software laufen hattest und sich.
Weißt du, was ich damals gemacht hab? Ich hab damals einen 100 MBit Hub benutzt.
Und ein Hub ist ein Netzwerkgerät, was den Traffic, der an einem Port, also der Traffic ist an allen Ports gleich.
Also du kannst mit einem Hub ohne Probleme den Traffic von Port 1 auf Port 2 bekommen.
Und da hab ich einen Hub genommen und hab den Hub benutzt, um darüber zu spielen.
Und dann hatte ich so ein ganz ollen, wie gesagt, das war 2005 oder so.
Ja, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Da hatte ich so ein ganz ollen HP-Notebook war das damals, glaube ich.
Da hatte ich dran und dort hatte ich dann die Radar-Software drauf.
Also sprich, ich hab die Daten abgegriffen übers Netzwerk von einem anderen Rechner quasi.
Und das war halt komplett undetectable für die.
Weil woher sollen die wissen, dass ich auf einem anderen Rechner Radar-Software laufen hatte?
Das war aber auch das einzige Mal, dass ich je gecheated hab in einem Multiplayer-Game.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Diablo 2 hab ich gecheated, da hatte ich auch Map-Hack.
Generell, ich hatte bisher die einzigen Cheats, die ich je verwendet habe in Online-Games.
Und das waren diese zwei Map-Hacks.
So, und das war natürlich in Dark besonders fies, weil wenn du in einer guten Gruppe gespielt hast
und wenn du auf andere gute Gruppen getroffen bist,
dann war es wichtig zu wissen schon im Vorfeld, welche Gruppe, Gegnergruppe ist das?
Und hast du für diese Gegnergruppe deine Abilities gerade ab?
Da auch gerade relativ hohe Timer damals auf den starken Fähigkeiten.
Da hast du teilweise Ability-Timer von 15 bis 30 Minuten.
Und wenn du die Gruppe gesehen hast, schon quasi 10.000 Einheiten, bevor die dich gesehen haben,
dann wusstest du halt, wer das ist und konntest dann der Sache aus dem Weg gehen.
Oder du hast halt gesehen, das ist hier easy-easy-Futter und konntest alles von der Seite wegklatschen.
Was man aber auch witzigerweise daraus gesehen hat, ist,
also was ich gelernt habe durch das Einsetzen dieser Software in Dark,
dass 70-80% der guten Spieler und der guten Gruppen es auch hatten.
Das hast du nämlich daran gesehen, wie die auf dich reagiert haben,
obwohl ihr euch im Spiel beide überhaupt noch nicht sehen konntet.
Also guck, du hattest dann, ich muss mal kurz gucken, da und da, mal gucken, ob es da vorne ein Bild gibt.
Das ist nicht wirklich die Software, die ich in Erinnerung habe,
aber ich kann es euch mal zeigen, sodass ihr euch das grob vorstellen könnt.
Hier hattest du eine Anzeige von der Map und wo Gegner sind.
Und du hattest auch die Anzeige, ich bin mir nicht genau sicher, was du alles gesehen hast mehr.
Ich glaube, du konntest sogar sehen, welche Spieler das sind.
Zumindest du konntest halt ungefähr erkennen, welchen Rang die Gegner haben.
Und das in der Zusammensetzung war relativ eindeutig, welche Gruppen das sind.
Und wenn du dann hier gelaufen bist und du hast die Gegner gesehen.
Stell euch mal vor, dass hier vorne die Gegner werden und du bist hier gelaufen.
Ihr konntet euch noch überhaupt nicht sehen. Du warst viel zu weit weg.
Und du bist dann nach links abgedreht und zufälligerweise sind die dann vorne auch nach links abgedreht.
Also du hast direkt gesehen, dass 80% der besseren Spieler auch Radar hatten.
Und der Hersteller war komplett machtlos dagegen.
Tja.
Das ist übrigens die Zukunft, sehe ich auch so, dass du gar keine RAM mehr auslesen musst vom eigentlichen Computer.
Weil dann ist es auch sehr sehr schwer nur noch zu detekten.
Ich kann euch aber sagen, wo das in Zukunft hinführen wird.
Das wird, also wenn das so ohne weiteres immer weiter also besser möglich ist und verbreiteter wird.
Irgendwann wird es dann so eine Art DRM für Bildschirme geben.
So nach dem Motto, du kannst Spiele nur noch mit DHCP spielen oder sowas.
Das ist die logische Konsequenz da draußen. So nach dem Motto, du kannst nichts mehr captchern.
Dann gibt es die nächsten Leute, die stellen eine Kamera vor den Monitor und filmen das.
Und das geht dann immer so weiter. Also diese Spirale aus Katze- und Maus-Spiel zwischen Hersteller und Anti-Cheat Hersteller.
Das wird nie enden.
Warum schicken die UDP-Pakete, wenn man in Game sich eh nicht sieht?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Nein, die schicken ja nicht die komplette Map. Also ich zeige euch das nochmal.
Also du hattest in Dao glaube ich eine Sichtreichweite von 5000 Einheiten.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Und bis zu 10.000 Einheiten wurde quasi geladen, was um dich herum passiert.
Ich denke mal, das war wichtig für mehrere Sachen.
Beispielsweise für Kill-Anzeigen, in welchem Gebiet was passiert ist.
Dass es nicht so ruckelt, wenn die Gegner dann wirklich reinkommen.
Dass das Spiel irgendwelche Sachen preloaden kann.
Alles mögliche. Ich denke, das hatte schon seinen Sinn.
Und der Hersteller hat damals auch versucht, ein paar Sachen dagegen zu machen.
Ja, es gibt in Dao beispielsweise Klassen, die können sich tarnen.
Und ursprünglich wurde die Position der Klasse, die sich tarnen können, auch übermittelt.
Aber du hast sie halt in-Game nicht gesehen.
Und dementsprechend gab es Leute, die wurden dann quasi enttarnt, obwohl sie getarnt waren mit Radar.
Was dann sehr auffällig war.
Und es gab damals dann Leute, die haben versucht, quasi Cheater zu überführen.
Indem sie sich Klassen gelevelt haben, die sich tarnen konnten.
Und die haben sich dann an Arsch der Welt gestellt mit der Klasse, die sich tarnen konnten.
Und haben sich immer ganz kurz getarnt und enttarnt.
Weil sie irgendwann eingeführt haben, dass wenn man getarnt ist, nicht übermittelt wird.
Aber wenn man sich enttarnt, erscheint man auf diesen Radar-Software-Dingern.
Und da gab es Spieler, die haben den ganzen Tag nichts anderes gemacht,
als sich hier oben an Rand der Map zu stellen.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Hier oben an Rand der Map zu stellen und sich den ganzen Tag zu tarnen und enttarnen.
Die haben sich enttarnt, haben dann 5 Minuten gewartet, kommt jemand?
Nein.
Haben sich wieder enttarnt, haben 5 Minuten getarnt, gewartet, kommt jemand?
Und dadurch haben die das dann, ja, quasi dann Evidence gesammelt und haben das dann dem Hersteller gemeldet.
So nach dem Motto, ich wurde von diesem Spieler 5 Mal an dieser Position gefunden,
obwohl ich mich dort kurz nur enttarnt hatte und sowas.
Daraufhin wurden Leute gebannt.
Aber ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das ist halt sehr, sehr schwer, da jemand zu überführen.
Der Hersteller hatte keine Chance, es irgendwie zu erkennen.
Ich meine, es war am anderen Rechner.
Ich hatte den Kram am anderen Rechner installiert und habe die Daten übers Netzwerk abgegriffen.
Vergiss es, kannst du komplett knicken.
Ja, die Sache ist halt, in Dark War der Support, gerade in Europa, so mega beschissen.
Die haben sowas selbst nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, hätten sie wirklich mal ein paar ihrer Game Master abgestellt, hätten gesagt,
hier, komm, 10 Leute loggen sich da ein und observieren mal so die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Ich meine, seriously, es gab auf jedem Server vielleicht 5, 6 Gruppen, die zur gleichen Zeit online waren,
die man hätte überwachen müssen.
Man hätte das easy rausbekommen, easy.
Die hätten einfach nur mal 5, 6 Leute gleichzeitig von ihren Game Master nehmen müssen und gesagt,
hier, du folgst dieser Gruppe, du folgst dieser Gruppe und das wäre so extrem obvious gewesen,
dass die am Cheaten sind.
Und hättest du mal die ersten 5 dieser Gruppen gebannt, ich denke, das hätte einen gewissen Abschreckungseffekt gehabt.
Auf der anderen Seite ist halt auch die Frage, wie viel Interesse hatte der Hersteller, das überhaupt zu finden.
Das ist ja auch immer so ein Ding.
Ein Hersteller ist da hin und her gerissen zwischen Leute bannen und Cheating akzeptieren.
Sie wollen eigentlich Cheating nur so weit einschränken, dass es, dass die Linie erreicht ist zwischen,
es vertreibt mehr Spieler als das Spieler verbleiben.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Also wenn sie das schaffen, dann ist alles okay.
Also wenn die Zahlen weiter gut sind, ist alles in Ordnung.
Und gerade in MMOs ist es halt fraglich.
Ich meine, wir reden hier nicht von MMOs, die 8 Millionen Subscriber hatten.
Die hatten teilweise Server, da waren abends 3.000, 2.000, 500, 3.000 Leute on.
Und das war dann relativ voll schon.
Und wenn du davon einfach dann, sag mal, 10 Leute, wenn du 5 Gruppen bannst, das sind,
also da waren das 8er Gruppen, das sind 40 Leute.
Du bannst quasi, du kannst quasi 40 deiner MMOs, naja, doch kann man sagen,
du bannst quasi 40 Leute weg, die massig Zeit in einem Game verbringen
und massig Monate lang bezahlen.
Ja, es ist halt die Frage, wie der Interesse, wie die Interesse des Herstellers ist.
Ich denke, man hätte schon durchaus mehr überführen können, hätte der Hersteller Bock drauf gehabt,
hatte er aber nicht.
Du kannst dich hundertprozentig was machen, aber guck mal, wenn du einfach nur,
ich meine, du musst das ja nicht groß ankündigen,
wenn die einfach mal 5, 6 Game Master genommen hätten
und wären dann zur Primetime den 5 üblichen, es gab ja nicht so viele richtig gute Gruppen,
die immer auch die mehr oder weniger gleiche Zusammensetzung hatten pro Server.
Da hattest du abends vielleicht 5, 6 Gruppen, der Rest war mehr oder weniger random
oder so Pickup-mäßig mit dem gleichen Player Pool, ja.
Aber du hattest nur 5, 6 Gruppen pro Server, die wirklich da besonders engaged waren in diesem Game,
die es besonders auf die Spitze getrieben haben.
Wärst du diesen mal gefolgt als Game Master, hättest du dir das angeguckt,
du hättest das garantiert gesehen.
Hundertpro.
So nach dem Motto, Hilfe, wir drehen jetzt zufälligerweise 180 Grad um,
weil uns 50 Gegner entgegenkommen, die man noch gar nicht sehen kann.
Und wenn das einmal passiert, ok, wenn das fünfmal passiert, irgendwie über ein paar Tage auch noch ok,
aber wenn das nahezu jede nur erdenkliche Möglichkeit passiert,
zu Entfernungen, die du quasi gar nicht sehen kannst, das ist schon sehr auffällig.
Wenig, ich sag ja wenig Interesse, viele Hersteller haben gar nicht so sehr das Interesse dran.
So, gucken wir mal weiter an.
Also als ich wusste, ich weiß Boomer Storys ja,
ich hab ja damals, wie gesagt, MMO Spielen war mein Leben damals,
ich hab da 24-7 gegrindet und gecheatet, teilweise,
und bugged the views, wie sonst was, ich war da wirklich,
deswegen, ich war ja auch übelst geschockt, als mein Account mal temporär gebannt war,
aber mein Account war nie temporär gebannt wegen Cheats,
weil wie gesagt, diese Radar-Geschichte war nicht feststellbar,
sondern weil ich den Account weitergegeben habe,
und derjenige, dem ich den Account weitergegeben habe,
der hatte sich irgendwelche Mailware auf dem Rechner eingefangen,
und darüber hat sich dann irgendjemand anderes bei ihm mit meinem Account auf dem Rechner eingeloggt
und Leute beleidigt im Chat.
Und ich wurde gebannt, Temp-Ban, ich glaub zwei Wochen oder so,
Temp-Ban, weil ich Leute beleidigt hab.
Und da hatte ich damals an den Support geschrieben,
hab gesagt, Jungs, warum bin ich gebannt?
Und da haben die halt tatsächlich auch Logs gepostet,
und ich hab halt die Leute übelst beleidigt, und das war ich nicht.
Aber Account-Sharing konntest du auch nicht wirklich zugeben,
weil dann hätten die gesagt, ja, selbst dran Schuld, ja.
Dann war ich zwei Wochen Temp-Ban, oder es könnten sogar vier,
aber ich glaube, es waren zwei Wochen.
Und das war ganz schlimm für mich damals Temp-Ban zu sein.
Das war mein Leben damals, MMO-Crime.
Und um nochmal eine weitere Boomer-Story zu erzählen,
wir haben damals auch wirklich so ziemlich alles ausgenutzt,
was es in diesem Spiel zum Ausnutzen gab, ohne zu cheaten.
Und du konntest in Dark wirklich richtig vieles Zeug machen,
weil das war dann MMO noch vor World of Warcraft.
Da wussten viele gar nicht, wie man gescheite MMOs programmiert.
Beispielsweise, habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt,
warum in World of Warcraft, und heute noch mehr als früher,
warum die Mobs zurücklaufen zu ihrem Spawn,
wenn du sie versuchst zu weit zu kiten?
Das liegt daran, weil es in MMOs davor ganz viele
Tricks gab, um an Loot zu kommen mit weniger Leuten,
mit weniger Zeitaufwand und sonst was,
weil du Mobs quer durch die Zone gepullt hast.
Und ja, sicherlich auch, dass du die anderen Leuten
nicht das Spiel versaust und Mobs in die Zone putzt.
Das ging ja in Classic World noch besser.
Da konntest du ja noch mehr Mobs rumpullen.
Du musstest ihnen einfach immer nur Damage machen.
Aber du konntest beispielsweise, in Dark konntest du Mobs
mit Katapulten pullen,
die dadurch, dass sie nicht dort bekämpft wurden,
wo sie eigentlich bekämpft werden sollten,
ihre Wegfindung nicht mehr funktioniert hat,
und du konntest die Mobs dann umnuken von einem Felsen,
weil sie da nicht hochgekommen sind und sowas.
Und du konntest sie ja mit dem Katapult rauspullen.
Normalerweise solltest du da rein in die Höhle,
aber weil die Collision Detection mit Katapult-Munition
nicht richtig funktioniert hat,
konntest du die quasi aus der Höhle pullen,
und dann war ihr Pathfinding kaputt und sowas.
Das war richtig hängen gefliebener Shit damals.
Das war, ja guckt hier, warte mal.
Da gibt es ein Video von, ich weiß, Boomer Talk,
aber da müsst ihr jetzt mal durch.
Das ist der Encounter Regulär, den man gemacht hat.
Okay, warum ist das jetzt auch Nacht?
Also das war hier so eine Schlucht.
Das war hier so eine Schlucht, da musstest du rein
und musstest die Mobs killen.
Und das war relativ schwer.
Und was du halt machen konntest, ist,
du konntest dich hinter die Schlucht stellen.
Mobs sind die Gegner in MMOs, Monster.
Du konntest dich hinter, moment, machen die das hier
sogar mit dem Katapult? Nee.
Du konntest dich auf die andere Seite der Schlucht stellen
und mit dem Katapult in die Schlucht schießen,
und da sind die Mobs rausgekommen
und hatten Wegfindungsschwierigkeiten,
und du konntest sie easy killen und solche Geschichten.
Du konntest auch, du konntest so krasses Zeug,
und wir haben wirklich alles abused,
was irgendwie ging, nicht an Cheats, an Mechanics,
was in diesem Game drin war.
Ich kann mich doch dran erinnern,
ich hab damals mit dem Masterkrabber Karsten,
weil ich kenne ja den Friseur und den Karsten aus Dark,
und ich hab damals mit dem Karsten,
wir haben zwei Wochen lang an einem Boss-Spot gecampt,
den man mit Tricks zu zweit killen konnte.
Das war eigentlich ein Boss für ein komplettes Masterlevel,
den man normalerweise mit 40 Leuten gemacht hat.
Wenn du dich aber richtig positioniert hast,
konntest du einen Heiler an eine Position stellen,
wo der Boss nie hin ist, und du hast, also du brauchst,
das letzte, was ich euch erzähle, versprochen, Leute.
Du brauchtest eine Pet-Klasse, also irgendeiner,
der Pets beschwören konnte, und einen Heiler.
Dann hast du ein Damage-Schild gemacht auf dein Pet,
und dann hat der Boss dein Pet geschlagen,
und dadurch, dass er dein Pet geschlagen hat,
hat sich selbst Damage gemacht,
weil dein Pet ein Damage-Schild hatte.
Dadurch, dass du deinen Heiler außerhalb gestellt hast,
wo der Boss nicht hingekommen ist,
konnte der Heiler dein Pet heilen,
und es hat 15 Minuten gedauert,
und der Boss hat sich an dem Pet selber totgeschlagen.
Und du hattest dann ein Loot für 40-Mann-Rates zu zweit.
Das ist halt schon, das ist halt schon geiles Zeugswaren.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, das Video war fertig.
Way, shape or form.
This is a virtually undetectable cheat,
because all the cheating software runs on a separate computer
from the one running the game.
So, from the anti-cheats perspective,
it just looks like a human player with really good aim...
Warte mal, irgendjemand hat grad noch was geschrieben im Chat,
was ich gucken wollte hier.
Grundsätzlich hast du recht, ich hab 2000 bis...
Du hast quasi auch von Release gespielt, ne?
Geil, war auch ganz schlimm, war auch ganz schlimm, ja?
Das Delta-Kram war auch ganz schlimm.
Also, ich kann dir nur aus eigenen Beobachtungen sagen,
weil, wie gesagt, ich hatte auch diesen Radar-Klampel an,
dass 70-80% der wirklich guten Gegnerkumpen das auch hatten.
Zumindest war es...
Ich meine, 100%...
Du kannst immer nicht beweisen, dass einer was nicht hat, so.
Aber...
Also, in dem Fall auch nicht 100% beweisen.
Du kannst halt nur sagen...
Er reagiert...
Zu einem sehr hohen Anteil so auf Situationen,
als hätte er sie gesehen, obwohl er sie rein mit Ingame...
Ingame nicht wahrnehmen konnte.
Welche Pizza wird heute bestellt?
Keine.
Keine, ich hab noch Spaghetti von gestern.
Das ist jetzt aber ein bisschen zu weit.
Also, ich mein, AI kann auch nicht zaubern.
Also, wenn dein Image...
Nehmen wir jetzt mal hier.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier diese Spielszene habe
und diese Spielszene quasi so geblurrt ist,
dass du keine Infos mehr draus erkennst, so irgendwie...
Wobei, ich kann jetzt hier grad nicht blurren.
Ich muss das...
Zack.
Also, AI kann auch nicht zaubern.
Also, wenn Informationen nicht da sind,
kann AI da auch keine Informationen rausbekommen.
What the fuck.
Ja, also, wenn das Ding jetzt irgendwie...
Wenn das Ding jetzt so aussieht in der Webcam,
dann macht da auch eine AI nix großartig.
Ja.
Also, du kannst die advanced AI der Welt haben.
Hier raus machst du keinen Headshot mehr.
Wo ist der Head?
Kein AI der Welt kann dir sagen,
dass der Head jetzt genau dieser Pixel hier ist.
Das funktioniert so auch nicht.
Ah, das ist das OpenCL oder was hat er hier?
Ja, ist es.
Äh, OpenCV und nicht OpenCL.
Gibt es OpenCL überhaupt?
Ja.
Das ist ja ein bisschen...
Es ist ein bisschen wie, als ich damals die Netzwerkpakete
über einen Hub an zweiten Rechner weitergeleitet hab.
Nur, dass es jetzt die Bilder sind
und das ist halt auch nicht detectable.
Würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Das würde ich nicht sagen,
dass es keinen Weg gibt, das festzustellen.
Also, das erste, was man versucht,
ist wahrscheinlich irgendwelche...
Dinge in-game nicht gut sichtbar einzuplenden,
die diese Bots hinter das Licht führen sollen.
Das funktioniert aber auch nicht.
Aber es gibt beispielsweise die Möglichkeit,
selbst statistische Auswertungen zu machen
auf Serverseite oder, sagen wir mal,
AI auf Serverseite wiederum einzusetzen,
um abnormales Verhalten zu analysieren.
Du kannst da schon was dagegen machen,
aber es wird für beide Seiten
immer aufwendiger und immer schwieriger.
Ja, du wirst auf dem Rechner des Cheaters
nichts finden mit Anti-Cheat-Software.
Aber serverseitige Auswertungen
Statistiken, Analysen über Input-Delay,
über wie zielt das übers Ziel hinaus
und AI, die AI analysiert quasi,
das wird es geben und gibt es auch schon.
Das Katze-Maus-Spiel wird es weitergeben.
Härtere Strafen bringt, glaube ich, gar nichts,
weil die meisten Cheater ja nicht irgendwie
im Profi-Umfeld agieren.
Also jemand, der beispielsweise professionell CS spielt
oder, sagen wir mal, semi-profi-mäßig spielt,
ja, für den ist es eh schon sehr gewagt, zu cheaten,
weil der weiß genau, was auf ihn zukommt,
wenn es rauskommt, dass er gecheatet hat.
Aber nachdem das normale Cheat von 0815 Leuten ausgeht daheim,
die werden sich auch nicht durch einen IP-Bun
beziehungsweise Mac-Bun abschrecken lassen.
Außerdem ist der beste, ist der beste Bun
theoretisch immer noch die CPU-ID.
Und selbst da bin ich mir nicht sicher,
ob man die nicht irgendwie faken kann mittlerweile.
CPU-ID dürfte eigentlich das Beste sein.
Dann müsste der Typ nämlich das komplette,
den komplette, oder du kannst eine Kombination machen, ja.
Mac-CPU oder sonst was.
Ähm, aber selbst da stelle ich es mir,
stelle ich es mir schwierig vor.
Ja.
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass du das machen kannst.
Ich gehe davon aus, es gibt jetzt schon serverseitig
AI, die Statistiken auswertet, um AIs zu erkennen.
Also wir sind dann irgendwann so weit,
dass du quasi AI-Polizei hast gegen AI-Verbrecher,
wenn du so willst.
Das haben wir ja schon in dem Fall.
Das muss ich erst noch zeigen,
ob es dort nichts gibt, was du wiedererkennen kannst.
Das ist quasi die Vorstufe zu Robocop, genau.
Ähm, ja gut, Mainboard tauschen oder CPU tauschen
ist ja schon eine größere Investition.
Das stimmt wohl.
Also, das wird weiter so sein.
Cheater versuchen zu cheaten,
Anti-Cheats bzw. Game-Hersteller versuchen
irgendwas dagegen zu machen.
Und dass sich das weiter in Richtung AI entwickeln wird
die nächsten Jahre, war absehbar.
Habe ich sogar mit dem Mathematikor mal ein Video drüber gemacht
vor drei Jahren oder so.
... existent überhaupt,
denn es passiert auf einem komplett separaten
und verbundenen Computer.
Richtig, Captures sind ein sehr gutes Beispiel.
Captures sind eigentlich dafür gemacht,
dass du sicherstellst,
dass zum größten Teil ein Mensch vor dem Rechner sitzt.
Trotzdem gibt es genug Capture-Verfahren,
die mittlerweile relativ gut von Bots und AIs gelöst werden können.
Und das ist ja genau das gleiche.
Die Capture-Hersteller versuchen,
dass man sie nicht austricksen kann.
Und die Austrickser schaffen es aber auch immer wieder.
Das ist ähnlich wie bei Anti-Cheat.
Die Cheats sind genauso wenig undetectable
wie andere Cheats vorher undetectable,
denn es wird nur immer komplexer auf beiden Seiten.
Und ja, ich gebe zu, das wirkt auch schon...
Das ist eine andere Qualität,
als wir können auf dem Rechner des Cheaters irgendwas nachweisen.
Oder wir könnten früher...
Früher hast du als Serverbesitzer mit Punkbuster
einfach einen Screenshot gemacht
und hast dir den Bildschirminhalt angeguckt
und festgestellt, der Typ hat irgendwelche Triangles
und Dinge auf dem Bildschirm.
So einfach ist es schon lange nicht mehr.
Aber die Spielehersteller arbeiten daran,
so was statistisch und AIs, die AIs countern, zu entwickeln.
Das ist denen auch klar.
Zumal man sagen muss, der Aufwand, sieht man ja jetzt schon,
der Aufwand, so zu cheaten, dürfte zumindest aktuell
für einen Großteil der Cheater unrelevant sein.
Die wenigsten Leute würden sich eine Capture Card,
eine Maus-Modifikation, mehrere Microcontroller
und die passenden Softwaregeschichten dafür kaufen,
um casual-mäßig in CS zu cheaten.
Also die wenigsten Leute würden 300 Euro dafür ausgeben,
um zu cheaten.
Was die Leute machen, ist vielleicht 20 Euro für,
wie hieß dieser Kram in Call of Duty früher, X11?
Ne, ne, das war das Linux-Ding.
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Was damals alle angeblich verwendet haben,
irgendwas mit X, oder?
Wenn du das für 15 Euro irgendwo kaufen kannst,
X23, X22, genau so was, genau das.
Wenn du dir den Kram irgendwie kaufen kannst,
für ein Apfel und ein Ei,
huch, was jetzt?
Dann machen die Leute das fix und fertig,
installiert und gut ist.
Übrigens wisst ihr, woran man sieht,
dass ein Game wirklich komplett am Ende ist?
Wenn die, ne, Kronos ist ja ein legit Device,
das kann man sich jetzt auch drüber streiten,
ob es das Cheating ist, wenn du mit Maus und Tastatur
an der Konsole spielst, aber das ist zumindest keine
Cheat-Software wie X23 oder X22.
So, wisst ihr, wie man dran erkennen kann,
dass ein Spiel komplett am Ende ist?
In dem Fall rede ich natürlich von Battlefield 2042,
wenn Cheat-Software-Hersteller sagen,
sie unterstützen das Spiel nicht mehr.
Es gab Cheating-Software für Battlefield 2042,
wo die Hersteller ein Abo verkauft haben.
Und ja, das ist wohl mittlerweile auch bei Cheating-Software
gang und gäbe, dass du dir eine Lizenz kaufst
für eine Cheating-Software
und die Updates du mit einem Abo bekommst.
Also es gab Hersteller, die haben Cheating-Software
für Battlefield 2042 verkauft mit einem Abo dabei,
dass du immer auf dem aktuellen Stand bleibst.
Und mittlerweile wurde das Weiterentwickeln
der Cheating-Software für Battlefield 2042 eingestellt
und man kann alternativ seiner Wahl das Abo umwandeln
in ein anderes Abo für ein Spiel seiner Wahl,
Call of Duty, Apex, was auch immer.
Also daran siehst du, das Spiel ist am Ende.
Wenn die Cheating-Hersteller schon sagen,
wir supporten das Spiel nicht mehr,
dann siehst du, es lohnt sich halt gar nicht.
Und wenn es für Cheat-Hersteller sich schon nicht lohnt,
können wir davon ausgehen,
dass es sich für DICE auch nicht lohnen wird.
Die Sache ist halt, es gibt Spiele,
die haben eine, sagen wir mal, kleine,
die haben eine ähnlich kleine Spielerbasis,
da lohnt sich das, weil die voll so dedicated Spieler haben.
Es gibt Leute, die grinden seit 50 Jahren
keine Ahnung, Mädchen 2 oder Ragnarok Online oder so
mit irgendwelchen Bots.
Da hast du eine Handvoll Leute,
die geben hunderte Euro aus für irgendwelche Bots.
Okay, dafür lohnt sich das.
Die Battlefield-2042-Spieler sind aber nicht genug
und nicht hardcore genug Geld auszugeben
für Cheating-Software.
So hat der Hersteller das halt eingestellt.
Daran sieht man, das Game ist halt dead.
Das Spiel ist endgültig dead,
wenn es nicht mal mehr Cheats dafür gibt.
Okay, ich guck mir das Video nicht an.
Ich will bloß gucken, was für krasse Links.
Arp, okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz klar,
brauchen wir nicht.
Ping, ping, krasser Tipp.
Abrechen, ping n, ja, System-Info, x-Copy,
Asoc, keine Ahnung.
Letzter Befehl, File-Taste, Internet.
Okay, da bin ich gespannt, was er dazu erzählt.
Internet geht nicht Trace-Route.
Da bin ich tatsächlich gespannt dazu, was er erzählt,
weil da ist viel falsche Sachen im Umlauf.
Das muss ich mir kurz anrufen, was er zu Trace-Route erzählt.
Was ich würde nicht sagen,
dass die meisten Cheater nicht dafür bereit wären.
Ja.
Ja, es gibt sicherlich viele,
aber ich kann mir trotzdem nicht vorstellen,
dass die Mehrheit, ich mein,
nur weil es auf höherem Skill-Niveau,
wo die Leute eh schon mehr Zeit in das Game reinstecken
und quasi da mehr Hardcore drauf sind,
dass die bereit sind,
sich da auch im größeren Stil Geld für auszugeben.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen,
aber insgesamt, insgesamt wirst du sicherlich mehr Leute finden,
die bereit sind, sich für 15 Euro ein, was weiß ich,
Modern Warfare Cheat-Abo zu kaufen,
Cheat-Software-Abo zu kaufen,
als einer, der 300 Euro ausgibt für Maus-Modifikation,
Screen Capture, die passenden Controller
und die passenden Software.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die das machen,
und es wird wahrscheinlich auch immer noch zu viele Leute geben,
die das machen,
aber der Aufwand ist zu groß für die meisten Cheater,
dass noch, noch das zu machen.
Sehe ich zumindest so.
Ja, und man kann sich eh darüber streiten,
inwieweit das ein Cheat ist.
Das ist schwierig.
Das ist so eine Grauzone, muss ich sagen.
Diese Chronos-Dinge.
Also wenn du mich fragst,
in Multiplayer-Spielen ist das klar ein Cheat.
Oder was ist denn Cheat?
Also es ist ganz klar ein Vorteil,
mit Maus und Tastatur zu spielen.
Auch ich hab das selbst ausprobiert,
muss ich sagen, ich hab so ein Ding hier.
Gerade weil ich, also ich hab das Ding mal ursprünglich gekauft,
weil ich mit dem Xbox-Controller
an der Playstation spielen wollte.
Das Ding kann aber auch Maus und Tastatur.
Und ich hab das auch schon ausprobiert.
Das funktioniert relativ brauchbar.
Aber es ist schon ein Unterschied,
ob du mit Input lag...
Nö, gar nicht mal so sehr.
Aber diese Devices,
die simulieren halt Controller-Input
von Maus-Bewegungen.
Also wenn du hier die Maus so bewegst,
das fühlt sich schon anders an,
wie du bewegst die Maus
über so einen
Maus-to-Controller-Emulator.
Das ist schon ein bisschen was anderes.
Deswegen, es ist,
das ist ein bisschen graut,
finde ich, ob man
das als Cheaten ansieht.
Ich meine,
man manipuliert
weder das Spiel,
noch liest man
irgendwelche Sachen, noch macht man automatische
Inputs.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich finde schon,
dass es ein ganz klares...
Man schafft sich Vorteile
über das hinaus, was das Spiel
normalerweise in der normalen
Konfiguration ermöglichen würde,
ist, ja.
Ob man das jetzt Cheaten nennt?
Tja,
ist schwierig. Ich meine, ja,
es ist Cheaten im Endeffekt.
Es ist Cheaten.
Aber wie gesagt, ich finde, es ist so ein bisschen
Grauzonen-Cheaten.
Batch-Script?
Ach du Scheiße, Igitt.
Nee, die haben erstaunlich wenig Input-Lag.
Wie gesagt, ich hab so ein Ding hier irgendwo, ich hab das auch ausprobiert schon.
Sind Makros-Cheating? Kommt drauf an.
Es kommt drauf an.
Also, ähm...
Wenn...
Es kommt auch ein bisschen auf die Regeln
auf die Regeln an. Also,
gehen wir mal von einem MMO aus.
Gehen wir mal von einem MMO
aus, wo du Klassen hast,
die...
...verschiedene...
...
Spells haben,
die aber eine
gewisse Abklingzeit
haben. Also, sagen wir mal,
ihr habt ne Klasse, die zum
Beispiel...
Ich spiel irgendein mittelalter MMO
und es gibt ne Klasse, die Lieder singen kann.
So. Und es gibt jetzt in diesem
Spiel eine Mechanik,
dass du verschiedene Lieder nacheinander
singen kannst und die haben dann verschiedene
Effekte auf die Gruppe, ja? Die Leute laufen
schneller, die Leute attackieren schneller,
die Leute heilen sich, sowas
zum Beispiel, ja? So. Und jetzt
ist das Spiel aber so
implementiert, dass, wenn du
ein Lied einschaltest
und dann ein anderes Lied,
ich sag mal ein anderes Spell machst,
dass das nicht direkt
aufhört, dass es noch so
10 Sekunden nachwirkt.
Ja, du machst nen Heelsong an
und dann switchst du auf nen Speedsong,
nennen wir jetzt mal Lucio aus Overwatch.
Und wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen würden,
das wäre nicht instant das Umswitchen,
sondern der Heel, sowohl der
Speedsong würden noch 10 Sekunden nachwirken,
nachdem du gewechselt hast.
So. Das heißt,
dann könntest du jetzt ja auf die Idee kommen, ein
Makro zu basteln, dass
deine 8 Songs einfach
automatisch hintereinander
umschaltet, sodass du
immer alle Songs aktiv hast.
Und dann ist es die Frage,
ist das erlaubt
im Regeln des Servers,
des Spieleherstellers oder nicht?
Weil du kannst
ja potentiell diese gleiche Sache
auch von Hand machen.
Du machst dir ne extra Leiste,
du musst dann halt theoretisch nur
innerhalb von 10 Sekunden immer
das hier drücken.
Oder sagen wir mal nur 3.
Du müsstest quasi,
während du diese Klasse spielst,
permanent das hier machen.
Damit alle Songs aktiv bleiben.
Das ist natürlich Abfall.
Und als man da auf die Idee kommt,
ein Makro zu programmieren, ist relativ klar liegen.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, ist das erlaubt
oder nicht? Also es gibt Spiele,
die erlauben das, die sagen, ja,
solange das Makro,
solange das Makro quasi
keine Logik enthält,
sondern einfach nur
repetitive Dinge, die du von Hand
ausführen könntest,
von Hand ausführt,
dann ist das okay. Genau.
Und das sieht man, das ist schön, schön, dass du es sagst.
Wer hat es geschrieben?
Am Badrand
hat es geschrieben, schön, dass du es sagst. Das wollte ich nämlich als Nächste sagen.
Viele MMOs
haben sowas mittlerweile.
Du kannst MMOs
teilweise spielen mit einem One Button.
Und das macht dann
die passende Makro Skill Rotation
schon für dich.
Du spielst dann DPS.
Du hast dann 8 Attack Skills
mit den passenden Cooldowns und sonst was.
Aber in Wirklichkeit musst du einfach nur
ab und zu mal
irgendwie einen Cooldown.
So, und das kannst du machen.
Schon eingebaut.
Schon eingebaut in das Spiel.
Das heißt, der Trend
in MMOs dahin, ist eigentlich
eher zu sagen, nein, sowas ist kein
Cheat.
Sobald man Rückstoßskripte
verwendet, ist das ganz...
Dann ist, finde ich, ganz klar, auch
keine Grauzone mehr. Sobald du Rückstoßskripte
verwendest und sowas, dann ist das eindeutig
Cheaten.
Korrekt.
Naja, ich spiel
MMOs deutlich länger als
World of Warcraft Release.
Also,
mittlerweile würde ich sagen,
also reine Wiederholungsmakros
ist was, was in MMOs
eher geduldet ist und nicht
als Cheat angesehen wird.
Wo es dann natürlich fraglich wird, ist,
wenn die Makros Logik
enthalten,
dann ist ja
der
Übergang zwischen
Makro und Bot fließend.
Also,
wohingegen ich sagen würde, hey,
wenn du einfach nur die gleichen
drei Spells immer, immer,
immer ausführst in, im
gleichen Abstand, ja,
dann ist es okay, aber
sobald du so Sachen machst wie,
aha, wenn ich jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt
einen Mob angeklickt habe,
der über 500 Lebenspunkte hat,
dann fange ich mit diesem Spell an
und wenn der Mob unter 50%
Lebensenergie ist, dann mache ich diesen Spell.
Also, wenn dann anfängt schon Logik
drinne zu sein,
dann ist das
die Frage, weil
wo hört der Bot auf
und wo fängt das Makro an?
Oder wo hört das Makro auf, wo fängt der Bot,
wo fängt der Bot an?
Ja.
Also,
deswegen sage ich ja, es hängt davon ab,
was das MMO bietet,
was das MMO erlaubt.
Aber der Trend
bei MMOs ist, wie gesagt,
spätestens seit es
beim World of Warcraft ganz viele Makros
Sachen schon eingebaut gibt, also
einfach nur Rotations
Wiederholungsrotations ist
eher was, wo MMOs sagen,
ja, das ist okay.
Genau.
Ich habe mich
nie mit Final Fantasy 14
Makros beschäftigt.
Ja, das ist dann auch
eine Regel, die der MMO Hersteller
aufgestellt hat. Die haben gesagt, hey,
wenn du Makros machst, die nicht mit
Ingame Makros abbildbar wären, ist das illegal.
Es ist natürlich die andere Sache mit
wie gut kannst du es erkennen.
Also, ich habe jetzt beispielsweise
Dark in letzter Zeit auf ein paar
Free Shards gespielt und dort war es in den
Regeln so, du darfst
Quality of Life Makros machen,
was im Endeffekt heißt, wenn du
Klassen mit Auras spielst, dann
darfst du die automatisch
die Auren durchdrücken lassen.
Das ist okay.
Aber irgendwelche Automatisierung darfst du
nicht machen.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was er zu
Trace Route sagt, weil zu Trace Route
kursieren,
kursieren.
Wie heißt das?
Sind einige Gerüchte im Umlauf,
die nicht stimmen. Bin mal gespannt.
Der nächste Befehl ist mal wieder sehr interessant,
wenn das Internet nicht funktioniert.
Das war der Befehl Tracer.
Wenn ich nämlich auf das Internet zugreife,
dann passieren da ja
im Hintergrund sehr viele Weiterleitungen.
Wenn ich jetzt von meinem Computer auf
Google.de gehe, dann gehe ich nicht direkt
auf Google.de, sondern als erstes wird die
Frage an meinen Router geleitet.
Der Router leitet das Ganze dann weiter an
meinen Provider. Dann wird das Ganze
irgendwann im Hintergrund über verschiedene
Umleitungen zum Google Server geleitet und
der schickt mir dann die Internetseite zurück.
All diese Punkte könnten ja theoretisch
einen Fehler haben. Das heißt, wenn das
Internet nicht funktioniert, ist es immer
sehr interessant herauszufinden, ob mein
Computer nicht funktioniert, ob der Router
nicht funktioniert oder ob Google
vielleicht gar nicht funktioniert oder vielleicht
mein Provider ein Problem hat. Das Ganze
kann ich mit diesem Befehl hier herausfinden.
Nein, kannst du nicht.
Kannst du mit Traceroute nicht.
Das höchste der
Gefühle, was du rausfinden kannst, ist
vielleicht, ob deine Fritzbox
aus ist, falls du
eine hast. Du kannst nicht
mit Traceroute rausfinden, was auf der Stelle
kaputt ist. Dafür tippe ich einfach
Traceroute und mein Ziel ein. Das sieht, ich gebe
zu, ich gebe zu. Die Ausgabe
sieht so aus, als könnte man das. Kann
man aber nicht. Das heißt zum Beispiel
www.google.de.
Wenn ich das hier eintippe, dann sehe ich
genau, wo ich hier
langgeleitet werde. Natürlich geht meine
erste Anfrage hier an die Fritzbox.
Danach geht es hier an
irgendwelche IP-Adressen und hier wird
gar nicht so genau spezifiziert,
welche IP-Adressen das eigentlich
sind. Das kann ich aber herausfinden.
Wenn ich jetzt wissen möchte... Ja, einfach
nicht IPv6 verwenden.
Die nächste
Anfrage hier ist nach
meiner Fritzbox. Dann
kopiere ich mir hier einfach diese... Oh, by the way,
das muss noch nicht immer gleich sein.
Diese IP-Adresse und gehe... So.
Und jetzt kommt das... Ich weiß nicht, ob
er es noch erklärt. Aber jetzt kommt das, was
viele Leute verwirrt.
Nur weil er an dieser Stelle...
Nur weil er an dieser Stelle
es so aussieht, als
passiert hier nichts mehr,
heißt es noch lange nicht, dass
es danach nicht weitergeht.
Das liegt
daran, wie TraceRoute funktioniert.
Und wenn irgendwas
dazwischen keinen Bock
hat zu antworten,
dann sieht das in TraceRoute so aus,
als
gehen die Sachen hier verloren.
Das heißt aber lange nicht, dass dieser
Zwischenschritt die Pakete nicht weiterleitet.
Wir gucken mal,
was kommt. In meinem Webbrowser
gebe ich jetzt diese IP-Adresse einfach
mal ein. Und da kann man auf
verschiedenen Internetseiten auch schon jede Menge
Informationen dazu finden.
Wenn ich beispielsweise auf
ipinfo.io gehe, kann ich die hier
eintippen und auf Suchen drücken. Und dann
sehe ich hier, aha, okay, die Stadt,
wo ich jetzt hinbeleitet wurde, ist
Vöring. Das heißt, es ist hier so
ein Kaff um die Ecke, oder
mehr so ein Industriegebiet, kann man sagen.
Offensichtlich wurde ich jetzt aus
München dorthin geleitet. Das Ganze ist
immer noch in Bayern, in Deutschland. Hier
gibt es auch die Koordinaten.
Und hier steht auch, welche Organisation
das ist. Und zwar bin ich jetzt
offensichtlich bei Vodafone gelandet.
Postleitzahl gibt es hier auch noch und so weiter.
Da kann man jede Menge Informationen
herausfinden. Und so
können wir jetzt einfach Punkt für Punkt durch all
diese Dinger hier, die hier raus...
Gut, gut, er zeigt, wie ich heute... Guck mal.
Nur weil hier nichts drinne steht, heißt es
nicht, dass hier irgendwas... Es gibt
Leute, es gibt Leute, die machen einen Trace
Hut und sagen dann, hoho, guck mal,
Packet Loss. Das stimmt aber einfach
nicht. Wie gesagt, das hat er nicht gesagt.
Nicht, dass William das jetzt nicht
in den Mund legen oder so. Aber es gibt
Leute, die sagen, guck mal hier, ganz viel Packet Loss.
Das stimmt aber nicht.
Diese Dinge antworten
einfach nicht auf ICMP.
Oder schicken keine, keine
ähm...
Fehlermeldung zurück.
Ob das Problem außerhalb ist oder nicht,
das kannst du im Prinzip auch schon allein schon feststellen,
wenn du deine Fritzbox pingst oder nicht.
Also, ja, okay.
Ich gebe zu, ich gebe zu, du kannst
erkennen, ob du bis zu deiner
Fritzbox kommst. Vorausgesetzt,
vorausgesetzt eine Fritzbox
antwortet drauf. Aber schon den
nächsten Schritt kannst du gar nicht mehr wissen.
Weil es kann durchaus sein,
dass der Vodafone-Router, der davor
steht bei dir, keinen Bock hat auf
äh... also...
Also ich muss erzählen, wie TraceRoute funktioniert.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Sachen.
TraceRoute kann über ICMP oder
TCP
funktionieren, aber es funktioniert immer
gleich oder immer ähnlich.
Ähm... es wird eine
TimeToLive gesetzt im Paket.
Die TimeToLive wird um 1 hoch
gezählt. Also du fängst an mit einer
TTL von 1.
Das TraceRoute ist kein Ping.
Ähm...
Das ist was anderes. Funktioniert auch ganz anders.
Also, du fängst an mit einer TimeToLive
von 1 in deinem Paket.
So. Was passiert
in einem Router mit der TimeToLive
im Paket? Also...
Header.
Nehmen wir mal...
Nehmen wir mal hier die TCP-Geschichte.
So.
TTL.
So. Also...
Ihr habt im TCP Header eine
TimeToLive. So. Was passiert...
Was passiert
im... in einem Router
mit...
Äh...
Ne, nicht IP. Ich will nicht TCP.
Ich will IP.
Hop Limit.
Hop Limit. Genau. Das da meine ich.
So. Das da.
Das hier meine ich.
So. Du
drehst die TimeToLive ein von 1.
Und was
passiert im Router, wenn er das Paket weiterleitet?
Der zählt die TimeToLive
1 runter. Wozu ist die
TimeToLive da? Das ist um Schleifen
zu vermeiden. Überlegt euch mal.
Irgendwie wäre...
Würde das Paket im Kreis geroutet.
Dann würde das Paket
ja unendlich lange im Kreis laufen
und immer wieder
neue Pakete dazu kommen, die auch im Kreis
laufen. Das heißt, die Pakete würden sich
unendlich lang im Kreis befinden.
Und es würde
sich vollstauen und irgendwann wäre
dicht. Deswegen gibt es
eine TimeToLive. Ich weiß nicht wo
die standardmäßig ist. 254
oder so. Kein Schimmer. Oder 108.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, was die Standard
TTL ist.
So. Und irgendwann
kommt der Punkt,
dass es an einem Router ankommt
und der Router
zählt die TTL runter auf 0
und dann verwirft er das Paket. So.
Und was TraceRoute jetzt macht, ist
TraceRoute setzt die TimeToLive
auf 1. Das heißt,
der erste Router,
der das Paket bekommt,
sagt,
oh, TimeToLive ist abgelaufen, ich
verwerf das Paket. Nachdem Router
in der Regel nett sind,
schicken sie dir eine Fehlermeldung zurück,
dass sie dein Paket verworfen haben.
Also du bekommst
eine Fehlermeldung zurück. Du bekommst
irgendeinen ICMP Error zurück.
Von dem Router.
Und anhand dessen weißt du,
aha, an dieser Stelle wurde
das Paket verworfen.
Es ist
quasi ein bisschen wie ein Ping, ohne
Ping zu sein, wenn man so will.
Also es ist kein explizites Hallo und Hallo
zurück, sondern es ist ein
Bitte leite mein Paket weiter.
Und dann als Antwort, ich habe
dein Paket verworfen. So.
So funktioniert TraceRoute.
Und das nächste Paket, was geschickt wird, ist
mit einer TimeToLive von 2.
TimeToLive von 2,
es geht über die Fritzbox drüber.
Es kommt erst beim nächsten Router an.
Also Fritzbox zieht die TimeToLive runter
auf 1 und die hier zählt die TimeToLive
runter auf 0, schickt eine Fehlermeldung
zurück, sagt hier, ich habe dein Paket verworfen.
Nächstes Paket, was rausgeschickt wird, ist
mit einer TimeToLive von 3, einer TimeToLive von 4,
einer TimeToLive von 5, bis ich irgendwann
dann dort ankomme.
Wenn
das zweite Paket eine andere Route
nimmt, wird es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber da verlässt man sich drauf.
Zumindest fällt mir gerade nicht ein,
wie ich das anders machen sollte.
Also das geht über die
TimeToLive von den Packages.
Und
was hier passiert ist,
auf Punkt 4, 5 und 6,
TraceRoute hat ein
Paket geschickt mit einer TimeToLive von 4.
Es kam
nie eine Fehlermeldung.
TimeOut.
Dann schickt
ein TimeToLive Paket mit 5,
es kommt nie eine Fehlermeldung.
TimeOut. Mit 6,
es kommt nie eine Fehlermeldung. Mit 7, mit 7
kommt wieder einer. Das bedeutet,
der Hop 4, 5 und
6 leiten den Traffic
weiter, schicken aber
keine Fehlermeldung zurück, wenn sie die
Pakete verwerfen.
Das ist das, warum
du mit TraceRoute nicht feststellen kannst,
welche Stellen
nicht funktionieren.
Oder besser gesagt,
dass du, nur weil
TraceRoute was anzeigt, es noch lange
nicht heißt, dass es kaputt ist an der Stelle.
Das ist die TraceSequence Nummer am Anfang
und nicht die TTL. Dann
widerrufe ich, was ich gesagt habe und
sagt, der Chat hat Recht.
Dann ist es die Sequence
Nummer am Anfang. Soll mir auch Recht sein.
So genau weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Aber vom prinzipiellen Ablauf her
ist es so, wie ich
erklärt habe. Und deswegen ist es nicht
schlimm,
wenn im TraceRoute zwischendrin
Sachen fehlen.
... rausgefunden wurden,
durchgehen. Und da können wir sehr genau
herausfinden, wo mein
ganzer Weg
durchgefunden wurde.
Wo mein ganzer Weg
lang geht. Das heißt, wenn
jetzt zum Beispiel nur der dritte Hopp hier nicht geht
und danach geht einfach gar nichts mehr,
dann wüssten wir, okay, alles klar.
Wir haben ein Problem mit unserem
Provider.
Ja gut. Okay.
Das einzige, was du sagen könntest, ist,
der nächste
Hopp nach meiner Fritzbox geht, deswegen
komme ich wohl raus und das Problem
liegt nicht an mir. Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Also, sollte der nächste Router
nach der Fritzbox antworten,
beziehungsweise eine
Fehlermeldung zurückschicken, dann kann
ich mir relativ sicher sein, das Problem liegt nicht an
mir. Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Das ist korrekt. Weitere
Annahmen kannst du
daraus aber wirklich nicht machen.
Und wenn der erste Router vom Provider
schon nicht antwortet, kannst du noch nicht mal
das.
Ja, und wenn er bei
Hopp 7 nicht weiterkommt,
bedeutet das im Endeffekt
auch nicht wirklich
viel, weil
es könnte auch schon hier nicht
weiterkommen, du weißt es aber nicht, vielleicht
antwortet er einfach auch bloß nicht.
Also, mal angenommen, ab dem
vierten Hopp, gäbe es nur noch
Timeouts. Es kommt nie an.
Es gäbe nur noch Timeouts.
Dann weißt du nicht, ist es der erste Punkt,
wo du es nicht antworten kannst,
dann weißt du nicht, ist es der erste Punkt,
wo es kaputt geht oder der zehnte Punkt, wo es
kaputt geht. Vielleicht antworten die auch einfach
bloß nicht. Also kannst du an Tracehood
wirklich nicht sonderlich
viel erkennen. Tracehood kannst du
so mal grob über den Daumen
gepeilt sagen, ja, okay,
sieht ganz gut aus, A sieht schlecht aus,
aber großartig
diagnostizieren kannst du damit nichts.
Beispiel, nur der dritte Hopp hier nicht geht und danach geht
einfach gar nichts mehr, dann wüssten wir,
okay, alles klar.
Wir haben ein Problem mit unserem Provider.
Das ist richtig. Das ist korrekt.
Da hat er natürlich recht.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Also wenn es aus deinem
lokalen Router rausgeht und du irgendwo
auf dem Weg danach noch eine Antwort siehst,
okay, ja,
das kannst du tatsächlich
damit feststellen. Das ist jetzt ein ganz interessanter
Sprung, den wir hier gemacht haben und zwar sind wir
jetzt von Unterföhring nach
Mountain View in Kalifornien,
also in Silicon Valley anscheinend gesprungen,
ja, und da haben
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendetwas auf dem Web Server,
was wir da runterladen, ja, da sind wir immer noch in
Mountain View und da können wir jetzt einfach mal gucken,
was da noch so passiert,
ja, also man kann jetzt einfach mal hintereinander hier
alle IP-Adressen eingeben
und einfach mal schauen, aha, immer noch
Kalifornien und wahrscheinlich werden wir da jetzt auch
bleiben und einfach von Rechenzentrum zu Rechenzentrum
geleitet werden, ja, schauen wir mal,
wo wir jetzt hier sind, aha, da
habe ich jetzt leider mein Tageslimit erreicht,
deswegen können wir hier nicht weiter gucken,
aber es gibt natürlich noch jede Menge ähnliche Seiten,
dafür einfach nach IP Info mal googeln
und da kann man jetzt auch die letzten
IP-Adressen noch angucken, passiert jetzt aber auch
nichts Spannendes mehr, wir bleiben hier halt einfach
bei Google, auch wenn wir hier beim letzten
wieder in Frankfurt am Main bei Google
rausgekommen sind. Mit dem
nächsten Befehl kannst du deine eigene IP
Ja, das mit den IPs ist dank Anycast
eh so eine Sache, wo
letztendlich der Server steht, weiß man,
weiß man nicht, aber anhand des Weges
kann man es ja, kann man es ja raus
rausfinden, so.
Jetzt, jetzt sind wir schlau, okay,
das Video war nicht verkehrt, ich dachte schon
wunderbar, was da kommt, aber es war schon richtig,
ähm, aber man kann nicht so wirklich
viel aus Traceroute rauslesen.
Larm an der Kasse
Moin Max, ich habe am Freitag mit einer neuen
Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
angegeben und mich an deine Tipps für den ersten
Arbeitstag gehalten, es kam übrigens sehr gut an,
dass ich kein illegales Netflix aufholen,
ja, das ist gut, dass du das nicht gemacht hast,
ja, du bist ja noch in der Probe,
du bist ja noch in der Probezeit,
da würde ich dir nicht empfehlen, illegales Netflix zu hausen.
Nach der Probezeit wirst du
und Azubi eh nicht mehr los.
Ich meine, wir wurden den illegalen
Netflix-Hoster bei uns auch nicht los,
der hat seine Ausbildung bei uns fertig gemacht.
Larm an der Kasse
Da gibt's ein Video zu, ja.
Da gibt's ein Video zu, äh.
Äh, keine Ahnung, wie das hieß.
Ich kann ja aber anhand des Thumbnails sagen, welches Video das war.
Da ist, da ist ein Keks hinter Gittern drauf.
Das hier.
Hallo Leute.
Illegales Hosting.
Das hier gibt's das Video zu, ja.
Wer das nicht kennt, wenn ihr wollt, können wir's jetzt auch zusammen machen, guck.
Was, ich hab noch kein Botnetz, was?
Ja, dann wird's mal Zeit.
Ich denk's, wollen wir das, wir können das gucken, komm, wir gucken, das eigenes Video
gucken, maximale Content Recycling.
Maximales Content Recycling, so muss das sein.
Leute, hier ist der Max und jetzt fragt euch mal selbst, würdet ihr euch trauen, was illegal
ist, im Rechenzentrum eures Arbeitgebers zu hausten?
Also, gehen wir mal davon auf, gehen wir mal davon aus, ihr habt die Möglichkeiten, ihr
arbeitet irgendwo in der IT.
Die meisten wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Und heute, einfach den eigenen Content nochmal ausschlachten, ja.
Beste.
Ich muss mich wirklich extrem aufpassen, damit ich keine Namen liege, also nennen wir ihn
mal Herr X.
Ja, so besonders anonymisiert heute.
Dellt euch mal vor, ihr seid so um die 20 und meint, ihr habt so die Geschäftsidee eures
Lebens und zwar ihr wollt ein besseres Netflix machen, so mit Filmen aus aller Welt, richtig
billig, ohne lokale Einschränkungen, also quasi alles das, was man vielleicht sagen
könnte, was er Netflix oder Amazon Video, was auch immer, nicht so gut ist, wollt ihr
besser machen.
Ist ja, ist ja so eine, sagen wir mal, eine ehrenwerte Idee, ja, und ihr habt auch schon
ein bisschen...
Der Typ hatte sogar damals ein Werbevideo gedreht für seinen, für seinen Video Streaming
Service.
Nämlich mit einem privaten Plex-Server und viel Speicher, ja.
Das war es so ziemlich, was ihr an Erfahrung habt in dem Gebiet.
Und ja, was macht ihr jetzt?
Als, also, natürlich neben mir jetzt ein Abo dazulassen, wenn ihr das Ganze nicht gemacht
habt, aber ich glaube, die meisten von euch wären wahrscheinlich so realitätsnah und
denken sich jetzt, ja, ich lass mir die Geschäftsidee vielleicht erstmal noch in Ruhe durch den
Kopf gehen.
Das hat sich Herr X. nicht gedacht.
Herr X. hat sich gedacht, klar, das ist doch überhaupt kein Problem, das Ganze könnte
man ja irgendwie geheim im Rechenzentrum der Firma hausten, für die man arbeitet.
Natürlich ist das doppelt illegal, ja, einmal das Hausten von überrechtlich geschützten
Inhalten, wenn man keine Lizenz und Rechte für hat, ist problematisch und zweitens,
das auch noch beim Arbeitgeber zu hausten, ja, aber es gibt Leute, die schrecken auch
das Ganze.
Das ist halt genau, chat, das ist ein richtiger Macher, genau.
Ich hab selbst nicht für möglich gehalten, aber ja, das gibt's wirklich, man hält manche
Sachen halt nicht für möglich, also heute erzähle ich euch mal, wie er das gemacht
hat und wie das Ganze ausgegangen ist und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, vor lauter Hosting,
wo kann ich denn ganz legal, ah, Sellout, der Sellout ist strong und easy meine Linux-Server
hausten, dann, erst mal den Sellout, ich geb mal kurz den Sellout, ich mach auf Twitch
öfters Streams, unter anderem auch zu diesem Thema, was, mach ich das, wirklich, wir haben
da aktuell so eine kleine Serie laufen, unregelmäßig, wo wir eine kleine Web-Anwendung programmiert
haben, Continuous Integration, Cloud-Servern, wir nennen das natürlich ein gutes Wort,
ich muss mir das mal abgewöhnen, ich, Max kommt zum Punkt, die letzten Monate, über
letzten Jahre über schon eigentlich, zu sagen, Stream, weil das so schön falsch ist, war
so ganz salopp gesagt, ja, also schneller, erst mal zwei Minuten rumgelabert, viel Bandbreite,
viel Anbindung, viel Speicher und natürlich auch ganz gut Rechenleistung, falls man Videos
Transcoden muss, Rechenleistung muss auch da sein, sowas hat man natürlich in einem Rechenzentrum
einer Bank, mitten in Frankfurt, mit fetter Anbindung, natürlich hat die Bank, in dem
Fall sein Arbeitgeber, wenig Interesse dran, das nächste Netflix aus ihrem Rechenzentrum
zu hausten, aber das hat der X nicht davon abgehalten, das Ganze zu machen, also, wie
hat er das angestellt, das war tatsächlich relativ trickreich, so trickreich, dass wir
da erst mal gar nicht drauf gekommen sind, und zwar, er hat die ganze Zeit erzählt, er
möchte den ESX, hätte ja klappen können, oh wenn das geklappt hätte, wäre echt problematisch
gewesen, ja, X Azubi Cluster neu bauen, ESX ist eine Virtualisierungstechnologie, da kann
man, ja ich erinnere mich noch dran, ich habe das ja erst richtig mitbekommen, als die Sache
schon schiefgegangen ist, Leute, die das gar nicht kennen, da kann man, merken die das nicht
am Traffic, anscheinend nicht, naja, außer ihm wird ja diesen tollen Service noch keiner
großartig verwendet haben, auf einer Hardware quasi mehrere virtuelle Computer draus machen,
die unabhängig voneinander laufen, das ist wunderbar, um, sagen wir mal, Hardware, die
auch ordentlich Power hat, gut auszulasten, parallel, mit Sachen, die ansonsten nicht
so gut zu parallelisieren sind, so, also, wir haben uns erstmal gefragt, ja was ist denn
auf einmal mit ihm los, ja, das stimmt schon, das stimmt schon, der war auf einmal voll
motiviert, ansonsten war er nicht so, nicht so einfach zu motivieren, und da war er wirklich
voll Feuer und Flamme für diesen Azubi ESX Cluster neu zu bauen, weil, er war jetzt nicht
so für da bekannt, so mit Einsatz zu glänzen, ja, und warum war er jetzt auf einmal so scharf
drauf, was zu machen, haben wir uns, haben wir uns schon ein bisschen gehofft, ich fand
es nicht schlecht, ich hab gedacht, guck mal da, der macht ja richtig was, aber da konnte
ja zu dem Zeitpunkt keiner mit rechnen, dass er so komische Dinge vor hat, und ich hab
von der Sache auch erst ganz am Schluss so richtig was mitbekommen, als die Kacke so
richtig am dampfen war, ja, es war eigentlich schon gelaufen, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das angefangen
hat, dachte ich mir halt noch, der will halt was lernen, der will was auch machen für
die anderen Azubis, warum nicht, und ich fand das gut, weil, ich hatte mich grad noch davor,
der war noch relativ neu, nicht jetzt irgendwie erst ein paar Wochen oder so, aber noch relativ
neu, ich hatte, nein, das war nicht der Endpunkt, das ist ein anderer hier, ich hatte mich tatsächlich
vor kurzem auch noch für ihn eingesetzt, ja, ich hab geschrieben, wir machen immer
Wende, das ist nicht der Niklas, mit dem Niklas hab ich ein Video gemacht, das ist ein anderer,
über den ich hier rede, der Azubi bei einem paar Wochen im Team gewesen ist, er war der
mit dem Anzug, genau, Zwischenbewertung schreiben dazu, und ich hatte in die Zwischenbewertung
damals noch sinngemäß reingeschrieben, so was in der Richtung, ja, dass ich, ich würde
ihn, oder wir würden ihn gerne öfters ausbilden, das weiß ich noch, ja, das war, da hab ich
mich wirklich komplett vertan, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, da war bei uns einer der
ersten Wochen sogar, wo er, nein, nee, nicht übertrieben, einer der ersten Monate, wo
er da war, und er hat mir damals auch sein Leid geklagt, er kommt jetzt gerade irgendwie
aus dem, ich glaube im Mainframe-Bereich war er, und da war er überhaupt nicht glücklich,
das hat ihm überhaupt nicht gefallen, und da hatte ich ihm ein paar Linux-Sachen gezeigt
und ein paar Linux-Aufgaben gegeben, und das hat ihm eigentlich auch ganz gut gefallen,
und ich hatte damals tatsächlich, wir schreiben immer für die Azubis, nachdem die eine Weile
in der Gruppe gewesen sind, Zwischenbewertung und Abschlussbewertung, also für den Azubi,
wie das so war, der Azubi darf, glaube ich, übrigens auch seinen Senf dazu geben, die
meisten wollen nicht, ich glaube, der könnte auch was reinschreiben, so, und ich hab damals
wirklich reingeschrieben, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, dass wir HerrX-Punkt gerne
öfters bei uns hätten, und gerne öfters ausbilden würden, weil dem hat's gefallen,
ich fand's nicht schlecht, ich, ich bin froh im Nachhinein, dass es nicht dazu gekommen
ist, weil, hätte er noch mehr Ahnung von Linux gehabt, und hätte er dann im Zweifelsfall
auch unsere Admin-Berechtigung gehabt, wäre das nochmal eine ganze Ecke, hätte nochmal
eine ganze Ecke mehr in die Hose gehen können.
Okay, der hat das verdient, man kann sich mal ein bisschen für ihn einsetzen, er hat
ja viel, er hat damals schon so viel Shit-Talk bekommen von allen Seiten, aber gut, aber
da war er auch, da war er auch schon ein bisschen selbstrandschuld, ich mein, das war jemand,
der hat immer absichtlich dann, wie soll ich, also, das ist ein bisschen, der war ein
bisschen wie der Twitch-Chat, ja, insofern, dass wenn du ihm, wenn du ihm gesagt hast,
ja, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, wir machen, wir installieren jetzt einen Samba-Server
auf eine Linux-Kiste, guck dir doch schon mal vorher an, wie die, wie man das config
technisch einrichtet, dann gucken wir uns das dann heute Mittag zusammen an, so, und
dann war die erste Frage von ihm quasi nicht, oder die Antwort darauf von ihm war nicht,
okay, ich meld mich dann, sondern der hat dann gefragt, wie der Chat, quasi, wie Linux,
warum nicht Windows, so, so einer war das, ja, also so nach dem Motto, ja, wir installieren
jetzt einen Fileserver auf Linux, und dann war seine Frage, ja, warum denn nicht Windows,
und wenn du gesagt hättest, wir installieren jetzt einen Fileserver auf Windows, hätte
er gesagt, ja, warum denn nicht Linux, der musste immer so absichtlich irgendwelche kontroversen
Dinge erzählen, aus Prinzip.
Äh, sind wir stehen geblieben, oder wo ist mein Video, hier, da, hat er nicht gefragt,
was seine Meinung zu C++ ist, die Idee ist ja nicht gekommen, warum nicht selber programmieren,
genau so eine Frage hätte ich mir von ihm vorstellen können, ja, einfach unglaublich
geil, hatte aber nicht wirklich großartige Ahnung, ist eh die beste Kombination, wie
gesagt, ich hatte mich damals noch ein bisschen für ihn eingesetzt, und es hat mich natürlich
gefreut, dass er jetzt auch was machen will, ja, ja, hat's mich, na gut, und aber zum Glück,
zum Glück haben wir ihn nicht öfters bei mir im damaligen Team ausgebildet, weil ansonsten
hätte er da seine Hosting-Versuche auch noch bei uns versucht, und wir waren zuständig
für alle unsere Linux-Systeme, und da hätte er, wenn er bei uns auch noch ausgebildet
worden wäre, zu dem Zeitpunkt hätte er wahrscheinlich auch Root-Zugriff gehabt, also Administrator-Zugriff
auf alle Linux-Systeme, da wäre sein Vorhaben wahrscheinlich noch einfacher und noch effektiver,
oh doch, ich, nein, ich unterstelle ihm nicht, dass er es böse meint, ich unterstelle ihm,
dass er absichtlich nerven will, oder absichtlich irgendwas kontroverses fragen muss, um, sei
es nur irgendwelche komischen Diskussionen auszulösen, ich mein, warum nicht Windows
ist bei einem Linux-Admin-Team relativ klar, oder, und ich hätte ja auch gar nichts dagegen,
wenn sowas gefragt wird, aber wenn solche Fragen immer kommen, ja, und in beide Richtungen,
der hätte bei einem Linux-Team dann, bei einem Windows-Team gefragt, warum nicht, warum
nicht Linux, doch, das war Absicht, doch, das war Absicht, da kannst du vorausgehen,
das war Absicht.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir die Chat-Historie so angucke, also wenn ich mir so deine letzten
Nachrichten angucke, ich glaube, du bist auch jemand, der gerne aus Prinzip wartet, bis
einer was sagt, was man missverstehen könnte, oder bis einer was sagt, wo dir irgendwas
kontroverses drauf einfällt, nur um das dann zu schreiben, und dir geht es sicherlich nicht
groß um die, um die Erweiterung des Horizontes, sondern einfach um ein bisschen zu nerven
im Chat, ja, prove me wrong, oh, oh, oh, oh, es ist hier ein falsches Video, der Flächel
ist ja da gleich, ja, wer weiß das, oder das Diskutieren, um einfach zu diskutieren.
Das ist so dreist, dass es schon wieder cool ist, ich hätte mich das im Leben nicht getraut,
natürlich ist es auch ganz schön bescheuert, ja, ich hätte mich das wirklich nicht getraut,
wisst ihr, warum ich mich nicht getraut hätte, so illegale Sachen, ich meine, ich habe damals
auch beim Provider meine Ausbildung gemacht, ähm, und da hätte ich ja noch mehr Möglichkeiten
gehabt, dort irgendwas zu hosten, ich habe das allein schon aus einem einfachen Grund
nicht gemacht, weil ich wusste, dass es illegal ist, und weil ich wusste, was es im Zweifelsfall
für Probleme geben kann, wenn ich sowas mache.
Das ist nicht so wahnsinnig big brain, aber natürlich war das ganze auch wie jeder coole
Service erstmal invite only, aber ein Werbevideo für ein illegal gehostet, bei seinem Arbeitgeber
illegal gehostet, ein Streaming-Service, ein Werbevideo für zu machen, das war schon wirklich,
das war schon next level dreist, also das habe ich so auch nie wieder gesehen, also dieses
Level von Dreistness, das hat bisher keiner mehr erreicht, na gut, ähm, zumindest ist
natürlich jetzt die Frage, wie hat er das gemacht, ja, er hat einen Cluster aus einigen
Kisten gehabt, angeblich für die Azubis zum üben, natürlich, natürlich, ähm, ich habe
bis heute nicht so genau verstanden, wie er das mit der Anbindung von außen gemacht
hat, ich weiß, mit der Anbindung ins Internet gemacht hat, ich weiß nur, wie gesagt, lief
ja glücklicherweise nicht in meinem damaligen Team, zum Glück, sonst hätte ich damit noch
irgendwas zu tun gehabt, zumindest, er hat wohl einen Proxy-Server verwendet mit seiner
lokalen Anmeldung, das war an sich schon mal nicht so big brain, aber ich habe bis heute
nicht verstanden, wie könnte man so ausdrücken, ja, wie er den Zugriff von außen gemacht hat,
ich vermute mal, er hat sich irgendwie getunnelt auf den Server ins Internet und dort dann
irgendwas weitergeleitet, keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, zum Glück nicht auf unseren Linux
System und zum Glück hat er damals keine Hutrechte gehabt und aufgeflogen ist das dann.
Ja, das stimmt schon, das ist ja auch an sich kein Problem, ja, also, ist es jetzt ja auch
nicht so, dass ich zwischenmenschlich immer alles richtig einschätzen, ups, zu laut,
es ist ja, es ist ja nicht so, als würde ich da zwischenmenschlich immer alles richtig
einschätzen, ja, das ist auch kein Problem, ja, und das ist da teilweise blöde Situation
gibt, ja, kommt vor, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob man Sachen wiederholt, absichtlich weiter
so macht, das ist ein bisschen so, ich weiß nicht in welchem Alter das ist, wo die Kinder
das machen mit drei, wo immer gefragt wird, aber warum, ja, wir gehen jetzt spazieren,
aber warum, ja, weil wir was einkaufen müssen, aber warum, weil wir was essen müssen, aber
warum, weil du sonst Hunger hast, aber warum, ja, das ist, es ist was anderes, ob du absichtlich
immer wieder mit irgendwas kommst, obwohl du weißt, dass es nervig ist und wahrscheinlich
dein hauptsächlicher Hintergedanke ist, ja, vielleicht nicht zu nerven, aber irgendwie
zu baiten, ja, oder ob du es einfach nur mal verkehrt eingeschätzt hast, ja, du kommst
dann auch wirklich schnell vom hundertsten ins tausendste, ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen,
ja, warum keine Pizza, ja, ja, ungefähr so, ungefähr so war das, ungefähr so, ja, im
Prinzip hab ich die Story jetzt ja schon erzählt, aber das war schon echt heftig, ja, Ausnahmen
bestätigen die Regel, aber dem bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, war das alles Absicht, was
rausgekommen ist, ja, es gab riesen Anschiss, aber er hat seine Ausbildung auch fertig gemacht
bei uns, gab, gab riesen Ärger, das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, warum die Spaghetti
nicht aufgegessen hast, ja, das ist so, ja, weil ich, weil ich keinen Hunger mehr hatte,
warum hast du keinen Hunger, warum, warum hast du, weil ich genug gegessen hab, warum
hast du genug gegessen, ohne, ohne, es war ja zum Glück noch eben, also er hatte das
fertig gebaut oder wie weit fertig das war weiß ich nicht, oder hat er ein Werbevideo
für erstellt, dass er seinen geilen Streaming Service hat, aber ich glaube es ging noch
nicht richtig los, also der hat eh saumäßig Glück gehabt, der hat wirklich Glück gehabt,
dass man das sogar raus bekommen hat, nee, nee, nee, es war nicht in der Presse, es
ist ja eigentlich auch gar nichts passiert großartig, dadurch, dass wir es gemerkt
haben, aber allein schon auf die Idee zu kommen, ist schon wirklich äußerst, äußerst
dreist, ich weiß gar nicht, was dabei, ich weiß nicht, ob er eine Abmahnung bekommen
hat, keine Ahnung, es gab auf jeden Fall einen riesen Anschiss, verfolgst du eigentlich 7
versus 1, nö, ich, hä, das war doch schon, oder gibt es da jetzt irgendwie reloaded,
nee, das verfolge ich nicht, aha, okay, was ist das Schlimmste, was du in der Ausbildung
gemacht hast, das Schlimmste war, dass ich nicht, dass ich zu blöd war, auf das Angebot
an der Weihnachtsfeier einzugehen, sie zum Zug zu bringen, das war das blödeste von
mir, das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, ansonsten, was habe ich kaputt gemacht, ich
habe mal unser Netzwerk kaputt gemacht, aber das war auf Anweisung, das war auf Anweisung
von jemand anderem und ich habe exakt die richtigen Kabel gezogen, aber das war hinten
dran nicht richtig konfiguriert, da konnte ich ja nichts für, auf der anderen Seite
ist das gar nicht schlecht Leute, dass ich sie nicht zum Zug gebracht habe, wer weiß,
was heute wäre, hätte ich sie zum Zug gebracht, vielleicht würde ich da nicht hirsetzen,
äh, wie handhabest du das Linux-Rewinner aus gleichzeitig zu haben mit mehreren Desktops,
mehrere Desktops und hier vor allem war Workstation offen, ja, hier habe ich die VM im Fullscreen
auf und dann switchte ich rüber, über Shortcuts zwischen dem ersten Desktop und dem zweiten
Desktop, die älter oder jünger, ich vermute mal 1-2 Jahre jünger oder so, ich war ja schon
relativ alt, als ich die zweite Ausbildung gemacht habe, ihr wisst ja, ich habe vorher
mal BWL Zeug gemacht, aber nicht viel jünger, lass mal überlegen, das war 2007 oder 2008
wahrscheinlich, 2008, da war ich da 24, oder, ich bin 84 geboren, war ich da 24, QuickMuffs
Leute, QuickMuffs, 2008, 1984, ja da war ich 24, ja die war wahrscheinlich auch 20, 22
oder so, ja, was ist das Aufzählen 1-2 Jahre komisch, hä, was ist daran komisch, 1 oder
2 Jahre, achso, du meinst, dass ich nicht sage, circa 2 Jahre oder so, pff, keine Ahnung,
geh mal auf den Kanal von Solution, glaube, da wurde gehackt, ok, sowas mache ich prinzipiell
nur aus meiner Lieblingskiste, wer weiß, was da los ist, X the Solution, was ist da los,
die Lösung, reject all, oh nein, seriously, schon wieder diese komischen Bitcoin Spacken,
die Crypto Pro Typen, schon wieder, Alter, wie heißt dein anderer Channel Solution Plays,
oh shit man, 41.000 Watching, na gut, das ist, das ist Bot, Bot geschildert, fuck, Alter,
Chat ist aus, ah, was genau passiert ist, keine Ahnung, ich hab das nicht mitbekommen,
ey, wie sieht mein Channel aus, ist da noch alles ok, Leute, Leute, bin ich, bin ich auch
Hacker Man, ne, alles doch ok, ok, gut, nochmal Glück gehabt, ja 2 Faktor Authentifizierung
bringt ja nicht zwangsläufig was, ich glaube schon, ja, oh, das tut mir jetzt leid für
ihn, aber ich glaube, der kriegt seinen Channel wieder, ich mein, der ist mittlerweile auch
auf was Streaming angeht groß, der hat da bestimmt die passenden Kontakte und im Zweifelsfall
kennt er die Leute, die jemand kennen, ja, aber du musst nicht zwangsläufig 2 Faktor
Authentifizierung umgehen, selbst wenn du 2 Faktor Authentifizierung hast, stell dir vor,
du hast dir irgendeine Möglichkeit eingefangen, dass einer deinen Rechner Remote steuern kann,
dann hast du ja eigentlich alle, hast ja schon gewonnen, dann hast du quasi einen authentifizierten
eingelockten Rechner oder du kopierst dir den kompletten Browser Ordner, inklusive Session
und allem drin, also selbst 2 Faktor Authentifizierung ist da kein guter Schutz vor und sobald man
das über den Rechner macht, der ferngesteuert wird, selbst dann zählen noch nicht mal so
Dinge, wie zufälligerweise kommt jetzt eine IP aus Indien und man wird mal geblockt, nee
nee, das ist ja der gleiche Rechner aus der gleichen Region, das kann YouTube nicht feststellen.
Theoretisch müsste es halt so machen, dass du bei jedem Browser schließen, deine Session
clears alles und deine Cookies löscht und so, aber das macht halt handhabungstechnisch
keiner, nee nee, 2FA hilft nur bedingt, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt YouTube auf und seid
in YouTube eingelockt und ihr fangt euch irgendeine Malware ein, die euren Rechner fernsteuern
kann, dann kann der doch theoretisch, so wird es nicht genau gewesen sein, aber nur mal so
zur verdeutlichen, dass es nichts bringt, dann kann doch jemand einfach sich einloggen auf
deinem Rechner, deinen Browser fernsteuern, wo du eingelockt bist und 2 Faktor Authentifizierung
gemacht hast und alles umsteuern, das sieht für YouTube so aus, als bist du das, dabei
ist das der Angreifer und da hilft natürlich 2 Faktor Authentifizierung nicht, es hilft
nur, wenn du halt, und das halt auch, sag mal nur um die Zeit zu verringern, wenn du
dein Rechner halt jedes Mal beim, also nee, nicht dein Rechner, wenn du dein Browser
jedes Mal beim schließen quasi Session, Cookies und alles löscht und halt auch öfters den
Browser auf und zu machst, dann ist halt so die Zeit beschränkter, wo das passieren kann.
Vielleicht wollen die das gar nicht übernehmen in dem Sinn, vielleicht wollen die ja einfach
nur Channelnamen und sowas ändern und das geht über deine eingelockte Session, keine
Ahnung, ja, also 2 Faktor Authentifizierung umgehen, glaubt, muss da keiner, man könnte
jetzt natürlich sagen, warum erfordert YouTube nicht zwangsweise eine 2 Faktor Authentifizierung,
sobald einer, sobald einer in deine Account Settings geht, da müsste man sich jetzt die
Details angucken, wie das gelaufen ist, wurdest du schon mal gehacksort, ja und nein, also
nie was YouTube und sowas angeht, ich hab mal meinen E-Mail Account verloren vor ein paar
Jahren, bzw. mein E-Mail Account wurde gesperrt, weil ich Spam verschickt habe, aber das war
halt bescheuert, wisst ihr was ich als Passwort hatte, Katze123 damals, das war kein so schlaueres,
kein so cleveres Passwort, Katze123, oh doch, oh doch, überleg dir mal, der Channel von
jemanden, den du abonniert hast, den du kennst vielleicht, lädt auf einmal Krypto Zeug hoch
und guckt mal an, wie viele dumme Leute es auf YouTube gibt, da fallen Leute drauf rein,
garantiert fallen da Leute drauf rein, es gibt auch Leute, die fallen auf Spam rein,
kann man sich auch gar nicht vorstellen, aber ja, Leute fallen auf Spam rein, sie haben
zufälligerweise 5 Millionen geerbt, aber wir brauchen 500 Euro Erbearbeitungsgebühr,
dass wir ihnen die 5 Millionen überweisen können, ja du hast recht, wir können froh
sein, dass diese ganzen Dinge nicht besser vorbereitet sind, weil wenn du wirklich einen
großen Channel gehackt hättest, dann und du explizit da quasi dich vorbereitet hättest
auf diese Channel, du hättest deutlich mehr Leute debaten können, wobei dann halt wieder
die Frage ist, ist der Aufwand angemessen, das müssen sich halt die Angreifer fragen,
also ja, du hättest sicherlich Videos zusammenschneiden können, dass es eher so aussieht, als ist
es quasi ein offizielles Julien Bam oder Solution Video oder der M-Core war ja auch, den hat
ich ja auch getroffen und dann irgendwie die Kryptosachen hinterlegen, ja ja, hätte man
auch machen können und so die Leute debaten.
Ne, was willst du da blocken?
Das geht ja über deine vorhandene Browser Session, da blockste nicht viel, ne, genau,
es lohnt sich, genau, früher hatte ich Katze 1, 2, 3, heute habe ich 1, 2, 3 Katze, Mist,
Passwort Leak, ja diese Scams kriege ich ja auch, die kriegt ja jeder, stellt euch mal
vor, stellt euch mal vor, irgendein Cam Girl kriegt diese Mail, ich habe deine Webcam gehackt
und nicht nackt gefilmt, dann sagt er eher Copyright, Copyright Verletzung oder schickt
mal, oder schickt mal den Film, ich brauche einen neuen Onlyfans Post, ich habe schon
2 Wochen nicht mehr auf Onlyfans gepostet, schickt mal her, ja die Scammer lernen, ja,
mittlerweile kannst du dich ja auch nicht mal drauf verlassen, dass die Mails in schlecht
im Deutsch sind, die lesen sich zum größten Teil richtig gut, ne, darauf zu antworten ist
natürlich zu zeitintensiv für die, wenn die schon merken, dass du, du musst das eher
machen wie die ganzen Scambaiter, du musst so tun, als bist du voll geschockt, du musst
sagen, oh nein, bitte nicht veröffentlichen und das kannst du dir ein bisschen Zeit klauen
noch, aber ansonsten, wenn die gleich wissen, dass du sie chibatest, dann, oder dass du
sie durchschaut hast, dann wird das nix, nein, das ist Hacking Content, Algorithmen verstehen
wurde da für ein paar Tage gebannt letztens, das ist ganz böse Hacking Content auf YouTube,
das geht nicht, ja, also die Scammer werden immer besser,
die Interpol Scammer, ich hab nen Kollege auf der Arbeit, der wird angeblich die ganze
Zeit von Interpol angerufen, hat er mir letztens erzählt in einem Call, gemeint, bei ihm würde
er immer Fake Interpol anrufen, Kid Boga ist, der Typ ist wirklich gut in der Sache, also
es gibt viele Streamer auf Twitch, wo ich mich frage, ich verstehe nicht, warum die
so erfolgreich sind, aber bei ihm, also ihm gönn ich jeden Zuschauer und bei ihm kann
ich auch wirklich nachvollziehen, warum die Leute das gerne gucken, ich mein, es trifft
halt meinen Geschmack, bei den anderen halt nicht, ich sag nicht, dass die anderen das
nicht verdient hätten oder so, es trifft halt nicht meinen Geschmack, aber da kann
ichs wirklich verstehen, der ist so gut auch spontan auf diese ganzen Scammer Sachen zu
reagieren, das ist auch ein Talent, was du haben musst, wenn er teilweise Faken muss,
er ist die Oma und lacht sich gerade kaputt dabei, nicht stundenlang, also ich könnt
mir das jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag 4 Stunden angucken oder so, aber ab und zu finde ichs
wirklich äußerst, äußerst nice, oh man,
wie geht denn der Interpol Scam eigentlich, ja ich hab mir sogar schon 2 Stück bestellt,
werden wir demnächst im Stream uns mal angucken, gucken wann das ankommt, das fand ich witzig,
dass mir das Video vorgeschlagen wird, weil ich wollte exakt, ah genau, zu diesem Thema
auch ein Video machen, ich hab sogar schon ein Textdokument mit irgendwie so 20 Sätzen
oder so, so ein halbes Textdokument voll, genau zu diesem Thema, mein Fazit ist, und
ich hab mir das Video schon angeguckt, deswegen sagt das auch, mein Fazit ist, dass es liegt
an zwei Sachen warum Spiele heutzutage so verschwitzt sind, das erste ist relativ klar,
die Hersteller legen Wert darauf, dass schlechtere Spieler nicht so sehr weggefickt werden,
um es mal ordinär auszudrücken, von besseren Spielern und, und das ist auch ein wichtiger
Faktor, der wird immer weggebügelt mit SBMM, die Leute sind heute auch nicht mehr vom Anteil
her so extrem Kacknoobig wie früher, es gibt immer noch unglaublich viele Kacknoobs, aber
von der prozentualen Verteilung her ist es ein bisschen besser geworden, heute musst
du keine mehr kommen mit, kauft euch ein gutes Gaming Headset, jeder der ein bisschen ernst
zu nehmen hat ein gutes Gaming Headset, die Leute gucken sich heute auch mal Tutorials
an, es gibt ja sogar Coaching was du dir kaufen kannst, relativ erschwinglich wenn
du das ein bisschen besser lernen willst, also die Kacknoobs heute sind nicht die Kacknoobs
von gestern, ja das ist tatsächlich auch ein guter Punkt, es spielen heute viele Leute
für online Schwanzvergleich, mehr Leute, das stimmt wohl, ja es sind mehrere Faktoren,
aber ich denke das sind die hauptsächlichen, die Kacknoobs von heute sind nicht mehr die
Kacknoobs von, wie wir sie noch aus Modern Warfare 1 kennen, selbst Kacknoobs heutzutage
haben grundsätzliche Sachen zum größten Teil drauf und natürlich sind die Hersteller
auch bedacht darauf, dass Kacknoobs nicht so sehr weggeknallt, weggebashed werden von
guten Spielern, ja im Prinzip sagt er ähnliches in dem Video, wisst ihr was, ich hab grad
hier der Gasnotstand, ich hab ne Gasheizung im Haus, das ist mega teuer, wisst ihr was
ich jetzt gemacht hab, also was ich machen werde, wenn der Gasnotstand wirklich notwendig
wird, ich werd einfach mit Strom heizen, ich nehm nämlich einfach meine Klimaanlage,
die kann auch heizen und gut ist, aber wisst ihr was ich jetzt gemacht hab, ich weiß nicht
ob das big brain ist oder komplett über reagiert, aber was ich mir gekauft hab ist, weil sowas
braucht man eh mal, ich hab mir noch einen zweiten Heizlüfter gekauft, weil meiner drüben
im Bad macht wahrscheinlich bald den Abgang, einen zweiten Hauslüfter und ich hab mir
einen Radiator gekauft für 80 Euro bei Amazon, wo man auch mit Strom heizen kann.
Der Anstoß war zwar, dass alle jetzt Panik schieben wegen Gasmangel, aber einen Heizlüfter
und eine funktionierende Heizung, die man auch mit Strom heizen, braucht man eh ab und
zu malen, ist nicht verkehrt und sei es auch nur wenn die Heizung ausfällt, bei mir hier
im Arbeitszimmer ist eh nicht das Problem, bei mir hier im Arbeitszimmer ist eh nicht
das Problem, da hab ich so viele Rechner und Sachen an, wenn ich die Tür zumache ist auch
im Winter warm.
Achja, es war eben die Frage irgendwo mit Altersvorsorge oder?
Davon fragen wir euch gegen Altersarmut absichert, was?
Ähm, ich hab ETFs, die aber dieses Jahr richtig beschissen sind, die Stonks, die Stonks sind
nicht der Wahnsinn, gerade, naja, gibt's noch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken können?
Ein neues Web-Framework, Leute, wann habt ihr das zuletzt gesehen?
Also das letzte Framework ist ja bestimmt acht Jahre her.
Ruby on Rails war das letzte Web-Framework, seitdem gab's keins mehr, das ist ein sehr
gutes Thema.
Was Cyberpunk gefailt lassen hat, können wir uns zum angucken, aber erstmal will ich
wissen, was es für ein neues Web-Framework gibt, weil das kommt ja nie vor neue Web-Frameworks.
Okay, das ist das wichtigste, Leute, heutzutage, ein neues Framework oder ein neues Produkt
oder eine Sicherheitslücke, die braucht zwei Sachen, die brauchen guten Namen und gutes
Logo, deswegen war Folina nicht so, Folina ist das mit Windows und Word und so, ihr erinnert
euch vielleicht noch dran vor ein paar Wochen, deswegen war Folina nur ein paar Tage im Gespräch,
hätte Folina mal ein ordentliches Logo gehabt, viel besser, der Name ist schon okay, der
könnte besser sein, der könnte besser sein, aber das Logo war, war nix.
Ist das der Deno-Dinosaurier, der sieht, ist das der Deno-Dinosaurier, der sieht bisschen
so aus.
Ah, es ist doch Deno.
Es ist
offiziell genannt Deno und nicht Deno, wie ich in diesem Video verspürt habe, aber der
Vorteil des Web-Frameworks ist, dass man den ersten Klasse Typescript-Support aus der
Box bekommt.
Außerdem kannst du deine App bauen und deployieren, ohne einen Build-Step.
Während die meisten JavaScript-Developer über 10% mehr Build-Times brachen, haben Deno-Developer
einfach keinen Build-Step.
Moment, das ist aber auch Backend, oder?
Das ist doch nur Backend, das hat doch frontend-technisch nichts zu tun.
Der Name ist gut, das ist ein geiles Buzzword, das muss ich mir merken.
Also, nur teilweise, was auch immer Hydration auf Deutsch heißt, ich weiß, was damit gemeint
ist.
Also, was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes, wenn du auf der Server-Seite was renderst,
den State einfrierst und zum Client schickst, und der Client taut den State auf und macht
dann damit weiter.
Aber was heißt Hydration auf Deutsch?
Hydration, alles klar, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid, ja?
Hydration Leute!
Was ist Hydration, man?
Als Hydration bezeichnet man die Anlagung von Wassermolekülen an Ionen oder Oxy, was?
What the fuck?
Alles klar, top.
Also, was damit gemeint ist, habe ich euch ja schon erklärt, aber die Wortkombination
ist toll.
Also, die verwenden React quasi als Template-Language auf dem Server, also auf dem Server wird das
Dynamisch ausgeführt, und das HTML, was rauskommt, kommt dann zurück an... okay.
Alles flautet.
Aha, du kannst jetzt quasi für Teile von deiner Website bezeichnen, wie du sie verwendest,
du kannst jetzt quasi für Teile von deiner Website auswählen, ob sie Reactive sein sollen
oder nicht.
Also, du kannst quasi Teile Server-Site rendern oder auch... okay, vom Ansatz her gar nicht
blöd.
Also, du kannst jetzt quasi Teile Server-Site rendern oder auch... okay, vom Ansatz her gar
nicht blöd, ob sie Reactive sein sollen oder nicht.
nicht blöd.
Also, du kannst jetzt quasi Teile Server-Site rendern oder auch... okay, vom Ansatz her gar
Flutter Dart, ja wir haben mal was ganz kleines in Flutter Dart gemacht.
Guck hier, Flutter, die Flutter App, da ist sie.
Achtung, Massive, ich zeige euch meine Flutter App, die ich damals gebaut habe.
So und hier, so und jetzt playen wir, ok Max, Flutter App, ja ja, Punkt mp3.
Ja, was ist das Problem?
Geht nicht.
Warum geht es nicht?
Max, mp3, does not contain any stream.
Ok, fast, fast, ich muss auch Argumente andingen, beste Anwendung überhaupt oder?
Auto Exit, so und jetzt auf gehts, Flutter.
Gut, das ist die einzige Flutter App, die ich je programmiert habe.
Cute App ist am Start, Alter.
Ok, beste, ja, Flutter Dart App.
Kann ich auch in meine Skillliste schreiben Leute, Flutter und Dart und was haben sie
in Flutter und Dart schon gemacht, eine cute Ayaya App, das überzeugt bestimmt alle.
Na gut, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen und dann sehen wir uns nachher wieder und gucken
uns ein paar Stellenanzeigen an und diesmal nicht rein Just For Fun, sondern wo ich gucke
wirklich nach dem was mich interessiert.
Bis dann, machts gut, CU.